Hey everybody, we're here with a duo episode. We've moved on to two episodes a month. I'm sure people have noticed by now, which is really, really cool. And I probably talk about that too much, but I just can't tell you how excited I am that we have an actual producer and we can up the amount of content that we get out to everybody, which is really cool. Exciting. Yeah. So this episode, we're going to talk about Hashmaps, which is really cool. Exciting. Yeah.
大家好，我们今天带来了一期双人节目。我们已经改为每月两期了。我相信大家现在应该已经注意到了，这真的很棒。我可能说得太多了，但我无法表达我有多么兴奋，因为我们现在有了真正的制作人，我们可以增加向大家发布的内容量，这真的很酷。令人兴奋。是的。所以这一期，我们要谈谈哈希映射（Hashmaps），这真的很酷。令人兴奋。是的。
So this episode, we're going to talk about HashMaps, which is really cool. So before we get into the actual show, I just had like a pre-show. I wasn't sure if HashMaps include hash tables or like what the umbrella term is. I think HashMaps kind of cover everything. I think they include, I know hash maps and hash sets are basically the same thing. Yeah, that's true. But then hash table, I mean, does that just mean you're using an array?
所以这一期，我们要谈谈哈希映射（HashMaps），这真的很酷。在进入正题之前，我有个预演。我不确定哈希映射是否包含哈希表，或者什么才是统称。我认为哈希映射涵盖了一切。我认为它们包括，我知道哈希映射和哈希集合（Hash sets）基本上是一回事。是的，没错。但哈希表呢，我的意思是，那只是意味着你在使用数组吗？
Yeah, I don't know either. We'll have to, we'll look it up. We'll look it up. Okay. But yeah, our show is going to be all about hashing and all the different things you can do with hashing and all the clever stuff that it unlocks. So we're really about that and i actually another thing i'm excited about is i got an oculus quest uh one of the quest twos and i think i think in our very first show i think i
是的，我也不知道。我们得查一下。我们会查一下的。好的。但我们的节目将完全围绕哈希以及你可以用哈希做的所有不同事情，以及它所解锁的所有巧妙功能。所以我们真的很关注这些。其实我还有另一件让我兴奋的事，我买了一个Oculus Quest，呃，Quest 2，我想，我想在我们的第一期节目里，我想我
talked about or maybe it was one of the first few episodes how i got a cell phone and how that was kind of a big deal and i was such such a, or smartphone, sorry, smartphone. I was a late adopter to the whole smartphone thing. Um, and I'm also a late adopter here. So I feel like I've been consistent, but, but I got a quest to, so I got, you know, Beat Saber and a lot of things that, that everyone knows about. And it's been fun. I've been exercising a lot with it. One of the things I was able to do with it that I didn't expect is, um, I've had a racing wheel. So it's like a USB wheel that actually clamps to my desk.
谈到过，或者可能是前几期节目里，谈到我如何拥有了一部手机，那是一件大事，我是一个，或者说智能手机，抱歉，智能手机。我是智能手机的晚期采用者。嗯，在这里我也是个晚期采用者。所以我感觉我一直很一致，但我买了Quest 2，所以我有了，你知道，Beat Saber和大家都知道的很多东西。这很有趣。我一直在用它做很多运动。我能用它做的一件我没想到的事情是，嗯，我有一个赛车方向盘。它就像一个USB方向盘，实际上可以夹在我的桌子上。
And it comes also with foot pedals. And so I'm really into racing games. And so I can play like F1 and Project Cars and Dirt and these other racing games with an actual steering wheel. And I've had that for a little while. But I actually was able to play a VR racing game with the wheel and the quest. So the quest has this thing called Oculus Link. And so you can connect the quest to the computer and use it, have your computer drive it kind of like the rift. So you can use the quest in this way.
它还配有脚踏板。所以我真的很喜欢赛车游戏。所以我可以用真正的方向盘玩F1、Project Cars、Dirt和其他赛车游戏。我有一段时间了。但我实际上能够用方向盘和Quest玩VR赛车游戏。所以Quest有一个叫Oculus Link的东西。你可以把Quest连接到电脑上，用它，让你的电脑驱动它，有点像Rift。所以你可以这样使用Quest。
And so with that whole like Frankenstein kind of of setup here with the wheel and the computer and the link and the quest i was able to actually do a racing game with like physical controls and vr and it was awesome like it was really really fun i was racing go karts and you could actually like as you pass someone you could look or if someone's behind you and you want to see how close they are you could turn your head and like look at them and then turn back it was really fun and even just the feeling of like you kind of like instinctively lean when you turn uh the steering wheel and so when i lean you know my head actually leans and the view changes and it was it was super super fun i have to admit it was a total blast yeah i also got an oculus quest 2 There's some, like I don't use Facebook personally,
所以有了这个像科学怪人一样的设置，加上方向盘、电脑、Link和Quest，我实际上能够用物理控制器和VR玩赛车游戏，这太棒了，真的非常有趣。我在开卡丁车，当你超过某人时，你可以看，或者如果有人在你后面，你想看看他们有多近，你可以转头看他们，然后再转回来，这真的很有趣。甚至当你转动方向盘时，那种本能地倾斜的感觉，呃，当我倾斜时，你知道我的头实际上也倾斜了，视野也变了，这超级超级有趣，我必须承认，这真是太棒了。是的，我也买了Oculus Quest 2。有一些，比如我个人不用Facebook，
like nothing against Facebook. It's just like, it's not something that I engage with regularly. So it was a little awkward that it's so heavily linked between sort of like Facebook, which you can go read about all on the internet and people have very strong opinions. Yeah, so I just set this up.
就像对Facebook没什么意见。只是，这不是我经常参与的东西。所以它与Facebook联系得如此紧密有点尴尬，你可以在互联网上读到所有关于它的内容，人们对此有非常强烈的看法。是的，所以我刚设置好这个。
I could talk to this. When I started it, it said, hey, do you want to create a Facebook account or an Oculus account? And I said, I'll create an Oculus account and try and keep things separate. So that way I can use key pass of a separate password, et cetera. So I went through like the whole signup flow. And then at some point really early on, I think it's like, I went to get my first game or something. They're like, uh, yeah, actually about that. You're going to have to link these two accounts. And the one you just created is going to get deleted in a year. I was like, what?
我可以谈谈这个。当我开始时，它说，嘿，你想创建一个Facebook账户还是Oculus账户？我说，我会创建一个Oculus账户，尽量把事情分开。这样我就可以使用KeyPass的独立密码等等。所以我完成了整个注册流程。然后在很早的时候，我想是，我去获取我的第一个游戏还是什么的。他们说，呃，是的，关于那个。你必须把这两个账户关联起来。你刚才创建的那个账户一年后会被删除。我说，什么？
Yeah. But aside from that, I also have enjoyed it. My kids have really enjoyed it. We do it in small doses and we cast from the headset to the TV so other people can watch. Wait, what? Wait, wait. How do you do that? There's an option, like a cast option on the main main menu so you can either you from your phone if you have it linked to your phone you can just watch it on your phone or tablet um but then you can also send it if you have a chromecast i think it also might support the what is the apple tv airplay i've not tried that yet but yeah that it's pretty cool experience i actually have the tool, I won't spoil it, is an Oculus Quest game that I put as tool of the show
是的。但除此之外，我也很喜欢它。我的孩子们真的很喜欢它。我们小剂量地使用它，我们从头显投屏到电视上，这样其他人就可以观看。等等，什么？等等，等等。你是怎么做到的？有一个选项，主菜单上有一个投屏选项，所以你可以从你的手机上，如果你把它连接到你的手机上，你就可以在手机或平板电脑上观看，嗯，但如果你有Chromecast，你也可以发送它，我想它可能也支持，什么是Apple TV Airplay？我还没试过，但是的，这是一种很酷的体验。我其实有一个工具，我不会剧透，是一个Oculus Quest游戏，我把它作为本期节目的工具
before we decided to talk about VR at the beginning. So I'll leave that for then. But there's been a couple of games I've really enjoyed being able to play and being immersive. One that was really different was, I think it's called Acron, which is like a permutation of the letters of acorn about a tree and nut-stealing squirrels. was I think it's called Acron, which is like a permutation of the letters of acorn,
在我们决定在开头谈论VR之前。所以我留到那时再说。但有几个游戏我真的很喜欢玩，而且很有沉浸感。有一个非常不同的游戏，我想它叫Acron，就像是acorn（橡子）字母的排列，关于一棵树和偷坚果的松鼠。我想它叫Acron，就像是acorn字母的排列，
about a tree and nuts stealing squirrels. And the interesting thing is that the person wearing the VR goggles is a tree that can throw, you know, sort of, I guess, like bombs and balls and whatever at squirrels that are running towards it, trying to eat the nuts that are at the base of the tree and take them back to their sort of base. But instead of having only bots do this, you can have other people on their phones download the game and take control of the squirrels. So they become the squirrels and you take turns,
关于一棵树和偷坚果的松鼠。有趣的是，戴着VR眼镜的人是一棵树，可以向跑向它的松鼠扔，你知道，某种程度上，我想是炸弹和球之类的东西，它们试图吃掉树根部的坚果并把它们带回它们的基地。但与其只让机器人做这件事，你可以让其他人用手机下载游戏并控制松鼠。所以他们变成了松鼠，你们轮流，
or at least we do, we take turns. Who's the tree? You have giant tree limb arms and you're picking up these things and throwing them at the squirrels. And the other people in the room are playing with you, right? They're the squirrels trying to come and steal your nuts. Whoa, that sounds awesome. And so it's super cool, you know, just like an experience that you wouldn't otherwise have. The only kind of like downside that I've gotten is one is like the battery life isn't super long, you can easily,
或者至少我们是这样，我们轮流。谁是树？你有巨大的树枝手臂，你捡起这些东西扔向松鼠。房间里的其他人正在和你一起玩，对吧？他们是试图来偷你坚果的松鼠。哇，听起来太棒了。所以这超级酷，你知道，这是一种你平时不会有的体验。我遇到的唯一缺点是，一个是电池寿命不是特别长，你很容易，
you know, taking turns with everyone, eat through the batteries. And then the second thing is you actually need a fairly large space for the games that don't have you stationary. For the games where you actually like move or walk around the space, which I find to be kind of like
你知道，和大家轮流玩，把电池耗尽。第二件事是，对于那些不让你保持静止的游戏，你实际上需要一个相当大的空间。对于那些你实际上移动或在空间里走动的游戏，我觉得这有点像
the most immersive and most cool. You actually need a fairly decent space that's clear of objects. So like a living room or something. You need probably a good I don't know what they recommend, like eight feet by eight feet or 10 feet by 10 feet. But it's actually surprisingly difficult, at least was in my house to like, find such a space. And so we had to kind of like make an arrangement where we move some of the furniture to be able to, you know,
最沉浸、最酷的。你实际上需要一个相当不错的空间，没有杂物。比如客厅之类的。你可能需要一个好的，我不知道他们推荐多大，比如8英尺乘8英尺或10英尺乘10英尺。但这实际上出奇地困难，至少在我家里是这样，找到这样一个空间。所以我们不得不做出安排，移动一些家具，以便能够，你知道，
have a big enough space to really fully enjoy it. Yeah, yeah yeah i was playing this game called i think it's called rocket rx but it's it's effectively like uh it's like solitaire solitaire tennis where you're surrounded you're encased in like a sphere and so you hit the ball off the sphere at different points to hit you know various targets and stuff that are like overlaid on the sphere right and so you're and the harder you swing well it's not's not, if you swing hard enough, then the ball will actually skate along the surface. So for example, if you hit it hard enough, then you don't have to like hit the target directly. You just have to be kind of a leading the target
有足够大的空间来真正充分地享受它。是的，是的，我当时在玩一个游戏，我想它叫Rocket RX，但它实际上就像，呃，它就像单人网球，你被包围了，你被困在一个球体里，所以你把球从球体上打到不同的点，以击中，你知道，覆盖在球体上的各种目标之类的，对吧？所以你，而且你挥拍越用力，嗯，不是，如果你挥拍足够用力，那么球实际上会沿着表面滑行。例如，如果你挥拍足够用力，那么你不必直接击中目标。你只需要稍微引导一下目标，
and the ball will kind of go through it. And so it kind of encourages you to swing a little bit hard. I don't think the harder you swing, the better it is, but you have to swing hard enough. And so I had drawn my guardian, which is what they call the sort of border you set up before you start playing. I had drawn it kind of right up to the wall and not really thinking about it. Oh no. Yeah. By the time the guardian warned me, like a split second later, I'd like punch the wall. It wasn't a big deal, but yeah, you easily like kind of lose track
球就会穿过它。所以它鼓励你挥拍稍微用力一点。我不认为挥拍越用力越好，但你必须挥拍足够用力。所以我画了我的守护者（Guardian），这就是他们在开始玩之前设置的边界。我把它画得紧贴墙壁，没怎么考虑。哦，不。是的。当守护者警告我时，就像一秒钟后，我就打到了墙上。这没什么大不了的，但是的，你很容易就失去了对
of where you are spatially. And that was one of the things that surprised me. I've only played it for a few days now, but surprised me was how often the Guardian is actually, you know, warning me, like how often I get far away from where I was originally standing. I also got a game called
你在空间中位置的感知。这是让我惊讶的事情之一。我才玩了几天，但让我惊讶的是守护者实际上，你知道，警告我的频率，我离我最初站的地方有多远。我还买了一个游戏叫
gorn g-o-r-n which is a uh it's like a roman coliseum and um there's a bunch of like weapons on the ground and so you actually reach down to the ground pick them up and uh and you have to sort of fight other people in this coliseum and uh it is i mean all of these games are a huge huge workout i mean i was sweating afterwards it was a lot of fun oh this is it feels like uh that movie wally you know like all the people like riding around in their you know chairs and drinking their slurpees like we're we can't go outside and exercise you know it's too much work so we're gonna put on these goggles and stay inside and exercise. It's just kind of, we're getting there. It's pretty wild. I mean, it's, it's, yeah, it's interesting
Gorn，G-O-R-N，它是一个，呃，它就像一个罗马斗兽场，嗯，地上有一堆武器，所以你实际上弯腰去捡它们，嗯，你必须在斗兽场里和其他人战斗，嗯，我的意思是，所有这些游戏都是巨大的锻炼，我的意思是，我之后出汗了，这很有趣。哦，这感觉就像那部电影《机器人总动员》（WALL-E），你知道，所有的人都坐在椅子上，喝着思乐冰，就像我们不能出去锻炼一样，你知道，这太费劲了，所以我们要戴上这些护目镜，待在里面锻炼。我们快要变成那样了。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，它，它，是的，这很有趣，
because it's definitely more of a workout than playing like Quake or something. So in a sense, it's like a step in the right direction as far as not ending up like a person in WALL-E. But yeah, you're right. It is. Actually, I saw a game in the store that said VR VR, where I guess you go around putting on VR goggles in VR. So there is, I think it's this Superhot. So I think Superhot, which I believe is available. We should say there's lots of VR goggles out there. I think this one's gaining momentum
因为它绝对比玩《雷神之锤》（Quake）之类的游戏更像是一种锻炼。所以在某种意义上，这就像是朝着不变成《机器人总动员》里那样的人迈出了一步。但是的，你是对的。确实。我实际上在商店里看到一个游戏叫VR VR，我想你在VR里戴上VR护目镜。所以，我想是Superhot。所以我认为Superhot，我相信它是可用的。我们应该说外面有很多VR护目镜。我认为这个正在获得动力，
towards being kind of more commonplace than just early adopters. Well, I think the quest is the only one that's self-contained, right? At least that I know of. I think there are others, but they're not at the same performance.
变得比早期采用者更普遍。嗯，我认为Quest是唯一一个自包含的，对吧？至少我知道的是这样。我想还有其他的，但它们的性能不一样。
Like they were much cheaper ones further back, like years ago. Again, we're late to the party. Yep. Yep. So in super hot, the,
就像很久以前有更便宜的。再说一次，我们是晚来的。是的。是的。所以在Superhot里，
which is an interesting game. They have, I believe it's there a scene where you reach up and pull down vr goggles onto your head to use your controllers to reach up and grab it and pull it down onto your head and it's sort of that same surreal thing wait i have on vr goggles and i'm reaching for vr goggles in vr to put on my vr dog oh it's amazing. I look forward to all of these little cheeky puns in these games as people start adopting these more and more. Yeah, I mean, another thing I did just for the experience.
这是一个有趣的游戏。我相信有一个场景，你伸手把VR护目镜拉到头上，用你的控制器伸手去抓它，把它拉到头上，这是一种同样的超现实的事情。等等，我戴着VR护目镜，我在VR里伸手去拿VR护目镜来戴上我的VR护目镜。哦，这太神奇了。我期待着所有这些小俏皮话在这些游戏中出现，随着人们开始越来越多地采用这些。是的，我的意思是，我做的另一件事只是为了体验。
Yeah, I don't think I would do it again, but it was actually pretty interesting was I watched an episode of Family Guy in VR. And so you're just like in this, like, I think you're in like some kind of a tree house or something, whatever that, you know, environment is when you start the quest for the first time you're, you're in this environment and there's basically just a giant, enormous TV that's just suspended in midair and it's playing family guy. And, uh, yeah, there's something just interesting about that experience. Like, like, I don't think I would do it again. Yeah. It's like, you might as well just watch the TV of course. Right. But, uh, there's just something kind of interesting about that experience. Like, I don't think I would do it again. You know, it's like you might as well just watch the TV, of course, right?
是的，我不认为我会再做一次，但这实际上很有趣，我在VR里看了一集《恶搞之家》（Family Guy）。所以你就像在，我想你在某种树屋里，或者什么，无论那个，你知道，当你第一次启动Quest时的环境是什么，你在那个环境里，基本上只是一个巨大的、巨大的电视悬浮在半空中，它在播放《恶搞之家》。而且，呃，是的，那种体验有些有趣。就像，我不认为我会再做一次。是的。就像，你还不如直接看电视，当然。对。但，呃，那种体验有些有趣。就像，我不认为我会再做一次。你知道，就像你还不如直接看电视，当然，对吧？
But there's just something kind of interesting about that. Part of it, too, is I was just surprised how comfortable it was. That really shocked me, actually. I think that having the strap that goes over your head and, you know, just getting
但那确实有些有趣。部分原因也是，我只是惊讶于它有多舒适。这真的让我很震惊。我认为有那条穿过你头部的带子，而且，你知道，只是把
all those straps, you know, tightened the right way actually made a really big difference. I think it's time for news. Go for it. What's your news? All right. My first one is a YouTube video called The Water Computer, or I guess it's called I Made a Water Computer by Steve Mould, which I guess he's a fairly famous YouTuber. I keep coming across YouTubers who have like a million subscribers and I'm like, I heard of this person before yeah i wonder what the percentile is there like uh i i bet there's there's there's got to be over a hundred thousand maybe everyone's probably groaning
所有那些带子，你知道，以正确的方式收紧，实际上产生了很大的不同。我想是时候看新闻了。开始吧。你的新闻是什么？好的。我的第一个是一个YouTube视频，叫《水计算机》，或者我想它叫《我制造了一台水计算机》，作者是Steve Mould，我想他是一个相当有名的YouTuber。我不断遇到拥有百万订阅者的YouTuber，我就想，我以前听说过这个人吗？是的，我想知道那里的百分位数是多少，比如，我敢打赌，肯定有超过十万，也许每个人都在抱怨，
like oh of course i already saw this video i knew this guy well i didn't i never heard of it so i came across this video by steve mold saying i made a water computer. And he is doing it with another sort of like math YouTuber, Matt Parker, which Matt Parker, I've watched his videos before. So I'm not sure I don't watch all of them. But I'm not sure how I miss this. Anyways, the guy has an interesting mechanism for building logic gates out of sort of plastic and doing the computation instead of electricity, you use water. And I just thought it was pretty cool. So in college, I took some amount of classes in digital logic, discrete logic, these kind of things about building up an entire CPU out of just gates.
比如，哦，当然，我已经看过这个视频了，我认识这家伙。嗯，我没有，我从来没听说过。所以我偶然发现了Steve Mould的这个视频，说我制造了一台水计算机。他正在和另一个数学YouTuber，Matt Parker一起做，Matt Parker，我以前看过他的视频。所以我不太确定，我不看所有的视频。但我不知道我是怎么错过这个的。无论如何，这家伙有一个有趣的机制，用塑料制造逻辑门，而不是用电，你用的是水。我只是觉得这很酷。所以在大学里，我上过一些数字逻辑、离散逻辑的课，这些关于只用门构建整个CPU的事情。
This is pretty common in a lot of electrical engineering or computer engineering curriculum. So I'm not unique, but I always just come back to it as like a sort of very enjoyable way to to kind of think about these like individual gates and how that they grow up up up and eventually you're playing vr on a headset so just to be clear like this doesn't mean a waterproof computer this is literally a computer that uses water instead of electricity oh okay so yeah i was about to get there thank you for making sure to clarify that yeah so this is like a class of people who have done what I guess what you call like physical computing, where instead of having like silicon logic gates, or it used to be, I guess, vacuum tube gates, you actually make anything that by having two physical objects, and then if both of them are in the quote unquote one state, then you know, and you have an AND gate, then you get some sort of output. So I've seen them built of Legos, of Tinker toys, of now somebody with, you know, flowing water. These are always just like super
这在很多电气工程或计算机工程课程中很常见。所以我并不独特，但我总是回到它，作为一种非常愉快的方式来思考这些单独的门，以及它们如何成长，成长，成长，最终你在头显上玩VR。所以要明确一点，这并不意味着防水计算机，这实际上是一台用水代替电的计算机。哦，好的，所以是的，我正要说到那里，谢谢你确保澄清了这一点。是的，所以这就像一类人，他们做了我猜你称之为物理计算的事情，而不是拥有硅逻辑门，或者过去是，我猜，真空管门，你实际上通过拥有两个物理对象来制造任何东西，然后如果它们都处于所谓的“1”状态，那么你知道，如果你有一个与门（AND gate），那么你就会得到某种输出。所以我见过它们是用乐高积木、Tinker toys建造的，现在有人用，你知道，流动的水。这些总是让我觉得超级
fascinating to me. And in theory, I mean, there's some nuance to using water for doing your actual computation. But in theory, you could build up a fully functioning computer using this. I mean, it would get unreasonably large. I mean, modern silicon has an enormous amount of transistors in it. So you would end up, you know, it wouldn't be practical, but it's just a fun, thoughtful way to see the kinds of things people are able to do.
着迷。理论上，我的意思是，使用水进行实际计算有一些细微差别。但理论上，你可以用这个构建一台功能齐全的计算机。我的意思是，它会变得大得离谱。我的意思是，现代硅片里有大量的晶体管。所以你最终会，你知道，它不会实用，但这只是一个有趣、深思熟虑的方式，来看看人们能够做的事情。
And so you actually build something they can add to, oh, I don't have it in front of me, two four-bit numbers or two five bit numbers. And then the output computation is a given by water flowing through this series of valves. So if you've never seen it before, you know, check that one out or just in general, you know, the fascination around using physical objects to do. Yeah. So when you go to take your SATs and they tell you, you can't bring your calculator, just be like's all right i got this guys uh can you please define calculator for me um yeah i just it's okay i don't need a calculator but can you bring me like 10 jugs of water
所以你实际上构建了一些可以相加的东西，哦，我面前没有，两个4位数字或两个5位数字。然后输出计算是通过流经这一系列阀门的水给出的。所以如果你以前从未见过它，你知道，去看看那个，或者只是总的来说，你知道，围绕使用物理对象来做这件事的迷恋。是的。所以当你去参加SAT考试，他们告诉你，你不能带计算器，你就说，没关系，我有这个，伙计们。呃，你能帮我定义一下计算器吗？嗯，是的，我只是，没关系，我不需要计算器，但你能给我带10桶水吗？
yeah can i have a 55 gallon barrel of water by my desk. Hey, wait, guys, it's still dripping. It's still dripping. Hang on. I need 10 more seconds. Oh, my gosh. Yeah, man, that brings back so many memories of I think that SAT you could have a regular calculator, but the ACT you couldn't have anything. I'm sure it's changed now. I haven't kept up with it. But I remember, yeah, there being like a specific list of approved calculators you could use. Yeah, that's right. That's right. Cool. Yeah, that sounds awesome. I'll give this a shot.
是的，我可以在我的桌子旁边放一个55加仑的水桶吗？嘿，等等，伙计们，它还在滴水。它还在滴水。等等。我还需要10秒钟。哦，天哪。是的，伙计，这让我想起了很多回忆，我想那次SAT你可以带一个普通计算器，但ACT你什么都不能带。我相信现在已经变了。我没跟上。但我记得，是的，有一个你可以使用的批准计算器列表。是的，没错。没错。酷。是的，听起来太棒了。我会试试这个。
Actually, you know, I was thinking about it the other day. A lot of the videos that are in my YouTube history are videos that you've posted. Really? So yeah, this is yet another creator. I guess another way of putting it is maybe not the history because that's too shallow, but like too recent. But a lot of the people I subscribe to are people that you found for me ah so uh cool i'll have to return the favor maybe next show i'll do uh are you have you heard of colin fursey yes yeah okay okay that's that's
其实，你知道，我前几天在想。我YouTube历史记录里的很多视频都是你发布的。真的吗？所以是的，这是又一个创作者。我想另一种说法可能是，也许不是历史，因为那太浅了，而是太近期的。但我订阅的很多人都是你为我找到的。啊，所以，酷，我得回报一下，也许下期节目我会做，你听说过Colin Furze吗？是的，是的，好的，好的，那是
one person that i found on my own so just for people who haven't heard of him on the show he does uh he just makes crazy things he's like a mechanical engineer extraordinaire and just builds all sorts of wild things the most maybe not the most recent episode but a recent episode he made a car uh waterproof um and the interior of the car is totally waterproof and so then he filled it up full of water and he had like a car that was also a hot tub what okay i've not seen this one yet. Yeah, you got to check that out. It's a convertible and it's a hot tub. And while you're driving, there's like water splashing out of the car and everything.
我一个人找到的一个人。所以对于节目中没听说过他的人，他做，呃，他只是制造疯狂的东西，他是一位非凡的机械工程师，只是建造各种狂野的东西。最，也许不是最近的一期，但最近的一期，他制造了一辆车，防水的，而且车的内部完全防水，所以他把它装满了水，他有一辆车，同时也是一个热水浴缸。什么？哦，我还没看过这一期。是的，你得去看看。它是一辆敞篷车，也是一个热水浴缸。当你开车时，水会从车里溅出来，等等。
All right, my news, one of my news is this really cool guide to something called attention mechanisms. And so I'm going to need to kind of, you know, explain and build up to this. But, you know, as a lot of people know if you want to do what people call supervised learning which means someone gives you a label so they say like okay here's a picture this is a dog here's a picture this is a cat here's a picture it's a dog they
好的，我的新闻，我的一个新闻是这个关于注意力机制（attention mechanisms）的非常酷的指南。所以我需要，你知道，解释并为之铺垫。但是，你知道，正如很多人知道的那样，如果你想做人们所说的监督学习（supervised learning），这意味着有人给你一个标签，所以他们说，好的，这是一张图片，这是一只狗，这是一张图片，这是一只猫，这是一张图片，这是一只狗，他们
give you a bunch of those you can do supervised learning and you could train a machine learning model to predict the output. So you could give that model a new image and it will tell you whether it's a dog or a cat. Actually, it'll give you the probability that it's a dog, the probability that it's a cat. Right. And so, you know, you might have, let's say a table full of data in Excel or something, and then you have this one column and that one column in the table, maybe sometimes it's missing. And so you want to try and predict the value of that column when you don't have it. And so you train a machine learning model to do that.
给你一堆这些，你可以做监督学习，你可以训练一个机器学习模型来预测输出。所以你可以给那个模型一张新图片，它会告诉你它是狗还是猫。其实，它会给你它是狗的概率，它是猫的概率。对。所以，你知道，你可能有一个装满Excel数据的表格，然后你有一列，那一列在表格里，也许有时缺失了。所以你想尝试预测当你没有那一列时的值。所以你训练一个机器学习模型来做这件事。
You take all the other columns, you pass them as inputs. That's relatively straightforward. You'd have some kind of neural network or some kind of model to do that. Now, when you have images, that's more tricky because an image, every single pixel, and really every channel of every pixel is a separate input. And so if you just use a regular neural network or some other model, it's just going to have too, it's too expressive, too open ended, and it can't really learn effectively. And it won't be able to handle different sized images and stuff like that.
你取所有其他列，把它们作为输入。这相对简单。你会有一个神经网络或某种模型来做这件事。现在，当你处理图像时，这更棘手，因为图像，每一个像素，实际上每一个像素的每一个通道都是一个单独的输入。所以如果你只是使用一个普通的神经网络或其他模型，它会太，它太具有表现力，太开放了，它不能真正有效地学习。而且它无法处理不同大小的图像之类的。
And so for images, they've made this thing called a convolutional network. And so the convolutional network's kind of nice. Think of it as like a roving eye. So it's like a little eye that can look at a piece of the image and that eye kind of moves across the image doing the same thing
所以对于图像，他们制造了一种叫卷积网络（convolutional network）的东西。所以卷积网络挺好的。把它想象成一只游走的眼睛。所以它就像一只小眼睛，可以看图像的一小部分，那只眼睛在图像上移动，做同样的事情，
at all the different spots in the image. And so if you know how to detect a dog, you know, in one spot of an image, that same dog detector will run everywhere else. And so you could end up with the output could be, let's say another image that's some black and white image. And the more intense the image image the more likely there's a dog there or not and that image is created by this this eye that kind of like roves over the image doing the same thing over and over again and because you only have to learn that eye once then it makes it practical to to to build these models and so it's cool for images but then you you have this you have like a lot of other modalities that you want to maybe learn from, right? And one might be language. So you might say, well, here I have a sentence and I
在图像的所有不同点上。所以如果你知道如何检测一只狗，你知道，在图像的一个点上，同样的狗检测器会在其他地方运行。所以你最终得到的输出可能是，比如另一张黑白图像。图像越强烈，那里有狗的可能性就越大，那张图像是由这只眼睛创造的，它在图像上游走，一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，因为你只需要学习那只眼睛一次，所以构建这些模型变得实用，所以它对图像很酷，但然后你，你有，你有像很多其他模态，你可能想从中学习，对吧？一个是语言。所以你可能会说，好吧，这里我有一个句子，我
want to predict whether this sentence is, I don't know, makes people happy or sad. And so you have a bunch of sentences and then you have a bunch of, you have another column that tells you whether the person was happy or sad and you want to train the same type of model but how do you do that with a sentence right it's not really clear like how to how to you know what sort of you know uh model or what sort of topology you need to do that and the thing that's especially challenging about sentences is that they can go on forever just and other than the image you know if there's, you know, the dog will probably just be in one spot of the image. Right. Or if the dog is going to be over the whole image, you could shrink the image down.
想预测这个句子是，我不知道，让人快乐还是悲伤。所以你有一堆句子，然后你有一堆，你有另一列告诉你这个人是快乐还是悲伤，你想训练同样类型的模型，但你如何用句子做到这一点，对吧？这不是很清楚，你知道，什么样的，你知道，呃，模型或什么样的拓扑结构你需要做这件事，而且关于句子特别具有挑战性的是，它们可以永远持续下去，而且除了图像，你知道，如果有，你知道，狗可能只会出现在图像的一个点上。对。或者如果狗要出现在整个图像上，你可以缩小图像。
There's tricks you can do where you only have to look at, let's say, a certain spot of the image. But for sentences, you can't do that, especially for certain languages and things like that. But even probably across all the languages, like the first part of the sentence might be really important when you're reading the end of the sentence. And so the sort of structure that they've designed to do things based off language is called LSTM, which stands for long short-term memory. And it's similar to this roving eye. I mean, it's a different technology, but it's similar in the sense that it uses a certain mechanism to kind of go over the whole sentence and be able to sort of build up knowledge as it goes through the sentence. So with all that groundwork, LSTMs are similar to convolutional nets that they didn't work
有一些技巧你可以做，你只需要看，比如，图像的某个点。但对于句子，你不能那样做，特别是对于某些语言之类的。但即使可能在所有语言中，比如句子的第一部分在阅读句子结尾时可能非常重要。所以他们设计用来基于语言做事情的结构叫LSTM，代表长短期记忆（long short-term memory）。它类似于这只游走的眼睛。我的意思是，它是一种不同的技术，但它在某种意义上是相似的，它使用某种机制来遍历整个句子，并能够在遍历句子的过程中建立知识。所以有了所有这些基础工作，LSTM类似于卷积网络，它们在很长一段时间内
for a really long time. And recently, people have been able to get LSTMs to actually work and be really accurate and train models that are really accurate. It's through something called an attention mechanism. So the problem with LSTMs are... So this LSTM, think of it like an accumulator, like a battery, right? And things are coming into this battery, like knowledge is coming into this battery. And this battery is sort of storing this knowledge. And then when you finish storing the knowledge and the battery now has kind of everything
都不起作用。最近，人们已经能够让LSTM真正工作并非常准确，并训练非常准确的模型。这是通过一种叫注意力机制（attention mechanism）的东西。所以LSTM的问题是……所以这个LSTM，把它想象成一个累加器，就像一个电池，对吧？东西正在进入这个电池，就像知识正在进入这个电池。这个电池正在存储这些知识。然后当你完成存储知识，电池现在已经有了某种程度上的一切
in it, now you can start draining the battery, draining that knowledge. So you could imagine if you're, let's say, translating English to French, you would store all this English knowledge and then you'd have another model that kind of drains it in French. And if in French you would have reversed the order of the words in a sentence, that's okay because the battery kind of has everything, right? The problem that they were having was as you store new things, they were kind of erasing the older things. And it's very hard actually to kind of keep storing more and more and more words without destroying like the very first word you put in.
在里面，现在你可以开始耗尽电池，耗尽那些知识。所以你可以想象，如果你正在，比如，把英语翻译成法语，你会存储所有这些英语知识，然后你会有一个模型，用法语耗尽它。如果用法语，你颠倒了句子中单词的顺序，那没关系，因为电池里有所有东西，对吧？他们遇到的问题是，当你存储新东西时，它们正在擦除旧东西。而且实际上很难，你知道，在不破坏你放入的第一个单词的情况下，不断地存储越来越多的单词。
And so the attention mechanism is a way to prevent that from happening. And so the article gets a lot more detailed than that, but this guide is really cool because it goes through the whole history and explains it kind of with pictures. And so if you've ever wondered how machine learning works on words,
所以注意力机制是一种防止这种情况发生的方法。所以这篇文章比那详细得多，但这个指南真的很酷，因为它经历了整个历史，并用图片解释了它。所以如果你曾经想过机器学习是如何在单词上工作的，
check out this guide. It's got a lot of good info. You make my news article seem so shallow. Well, that's probably the deepest one I've ever linked. So sample size of one. Yeah, that's super fascinating. I think that was a great overview. I knew all of those words. My news article is another abrupt 180 degree different direction, which is the successful launch and landing of Starship SN15. So we have like a little bit, I guess Jason was mentioning about being a late adopter to smartphones.
看看这个指南。它有很多好的信息。你让我的新闻文章看起来太浅了。嗯，那可能是我链接过的最深的一篇。所以样本量为一。是的，这超级迷人。我认为那是一个很好的概述。我认识所有那些词。我的新闻文章是另一个突然180度大转弯的不同方向，也就是Starship SN15的成功发射和着陆。所以我们有，我猜Jason提到关于成为智能手机的晚期采用者。
We have a history as well as covering some amounts of space articles and making space predictions. This happened a couple of weeks ago while we're recording this. So it's sort of old news, but I just want to celebrate. I think it's super cool.
我们也有涵盖一些太空文章和做出太空预测的历史。这发生在我们录制这期节目几周前。所以这算是旧闻了，但我只是想庆祝一下。我认为这超级酷。
This is a SpaceX prototype and they were able to launch it out of Texas up to, I don't remember where they go, up to about 10 kilometers or something and then land it back just next to where it took off from. But just the whole thing flying and launching it, it looks so ridiculous and to actually see them do it successfully.
这是一个SpaceX原型，他们能够把它从德克萨斯州发射到，我不记得他们去了哪里，大约10公里左右，然后把它降落在离起飞点旁边。但整个飞行和发射过程，看起来太荒谬了，能真正看到他们成功做到这一点。
They've managed to sort of land before, but there was always problems of one kind or another and so this is the first time they sort of took off landed no major issues and in fact they're looking to potentially do it again i guess they're doing inspections and stuff so oh i was gonna ask about that because i thought they had done it before but yeah maybe there were problems you know it might have looked like it landed, but something broke or something. Yeah. And there was also the, they did tests earlier, which were not as high and weren't, didn't have aerodynamic surfaces.
他们之前设法着陆过，但总是有这样那样的问题，所以这是他们第一次起飞、着陆，没有重大问题，事实上他们正在考虑再次这样做，我猜他们正在做检查之类的，所以哦，我正要问那个，因为我以为他们以前做过，但是的，也许有问题，你知道，它看起来可能着陆了，但有什么东西坏了之类的。是的。而且还有，他们之前做了测试，没有那么高，也没有空气动力学表面。
So they did some like tests of the engines and stuff. This is the first time they sort of sent up what would end up being the final stage, like the orbital part of the thing. And now it looks like they're, based on filings, they're thinking about launching up to orbit from Texas and splashing down somewhere around Hawaii sometime soon, which would require I think them to stack two stages together. So this thing's huge. If you've not, go look at the like diagrams for how big the final thing is going to be compared to like a person or existing launch vehicles. And it's it's absolutely insane.
所以他们做了一些引擎测试之类的。这是他们第一次发送最终阶段，就像轨道部分的东西。现在看起来，根据备案，他们正在考虑很快从德克萨斯州发射到轨道，并在夏威夷附近溅落，这需要我认为他们把两个阶段堆叠在一起。所以这个东西很大。如果你没有，去看看最终的东西将有多大的图表，与人或现有的运载火箭相比。这绝对是疯狂的。
Wow, it's amazing. Yeah, the so how far are we away from being able to get a ride on one of those as a passenger? You and me or an arbitrary rich person? Let's say let's say an arbitrary rich person. I mean, I think they're going to fly several civilian launches this year. I think SpaceX is doing one on the Falcon. Their current ones that go up to the space station, they're going to launch some civilians, which will sort of kick off another set of civilian space travel, which hasn't happened for a few years. But I think on Starship, I would say probably still sort of two or three years away.
哇，太神奇了。是的，那么我们离能够作为乘客乘坐其中一个还有多远？你和我，还是一个任意的富人？假设，假设一个任意的富人。我的意思是，我认为他们今年会进行几次平民发射。我认为SpaceX正在猎鹰上进行一次。他们目前去空间站的那些，他们将发射一些平民，这将开启另一套平民太空旅行，这已经几年没发生了。但我认为在Starship上，我会说可能还需要两三年。
I mean, there's the Japanese person who bought a trip around the moon on one of these starships, and they haven't set an exact date yet. But I think they're saying it's going to be closer than you think. Wow, it's amazing. Now you and I affording it? Yeah, that's a that's a whole nother question. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe if i if uh yeah we stop you know buying so much junk food maybe we can get there how much dogecoin did you buy oh gosh oh yeah yeah last show um or a couple shows ago a few years ago we're talking about you know like fractures or banking and those things, the last duo episode. And since then, people have been trading their dollars for dog money. So I think that just kind of tells you
我的意思是，有那个买了环月旅行的日本人，他们还没有设定确切的日期。但我认为他们说这会比你想象的要近。哇，太神奇了。现在你和我负担得起吗？是的，那是另一个问题。是的。也许如果我们，如果我们停止，你知道，买那么多垃圾食品，也许我们可以做到。你买了多少狗狗币？哦，天哪，哦，是的，是的，上期节目，或者几期节目以前，几年前，我们谈论的是，你知道，比如破产或银行之类的，上一期双人节目。从那时起，人们一直在用他们的美元换狗钱。所以我认为这只是告诉你
everything you need to know. So okay, my second news article is on MailSync. So I actually use MailSpring. If you've ever gotten an email from me recently, you'll actually see this little footer because I've never bothered to change the default, which is great advertising for them. You'll see this little footer saying MailSpring, the best free email app or something like that. But I actually love MailSpring. We should definitely do it as a tool to show some time if I haven't already. But it's a nice desktop email app. It has a lot of really nice features. It collects all your inboxes. I just feel like it has a great interface.
你需要知道的一切。所以好的，我的第二个新闻文章是关于MailSync。所以我实际上使用MailSpring。如果你最近收到过我的邮件，你实际上会看到这个小页脚，因为我从来没费心去更改默认设置，这对他们来说是很好的广告。你会看到这个小页脚，写着MailSpring，最好的免费电子邮件应用程序之类的。但我实际上很喜欢MailSpring。如果我还没做过的话，我们绝对应该把它作为工具来展示。但它是一个不错的桌面电子邮件应用程序。它有很多非常好的功能。它收集了你所有的收件箱。我只是觉得它有一个很棒的界面。
I'm a big fan. And for a while, the MailSpring kind of front end, which is all in Electron, was open source. But the back end, which actually handled ingesting mail from a trillion different sources, they handle Exchange, they handle Gmail, they do all of that. That was all closed source. And so I don't remember if MailSpring is on Linux. I know it's on Mac and Windows. I'm sure it's on Linux too, but, but in general, like you always, when somebody is closed source, you always kind of wonder how long it's going to survive. And, uh, and now they recently decided to open source
我是个大粉丝。有一段时间，MailSpring的前端，全是用Electron写的，是开源的。但后端，实际上处理从一万亿个不同来源摄取邮件，他们处理Exchange，他们处理Gmail，他们做所有这些。那全是闭源的。所以我记不清MailSpring是否在Linux上。我知道它在Mac和Windows上。我肯定它也在Linux上，但，但总的来说，就像你总是，当有人闭源时，你总是会想它能存活多久。而且，呃，现在他们最近决定开源
the whole backend, which is really cool. Um, not only does it mean mail spring will be around for forever, but, um, also, um, if you ever needed to do that, like if you needed to ingest mail, and basically MailSync basically converts email into think of it as like a SQL light table. And so if you ever needed sort of a database representation of your email, and one that sort of is kept kept in sync and kept alive, kept alive. MailSync does exactly that. And so I think it's a really nice thing to have for the community. So I'm really excited about all of that. I think email is still an area where there's a lot of low-hanging fruit. I mean, I spend a ton of time on email. Something you know, organized email. I do think there is something to that. And this will sort of open up that where people can write new front
整个后端，这真的很酷。嗯，这不仅意味着MailSpring将永远存在，而且，嗯，如果你曾经需要这样做，比如如果你需要摄取邮件，基本上MailSync基本上把电子邮件转换成，把它想象成一个SQL light表。所以如果你曾经需要某种电子邮件的数据库表示，并且是一个保持同步并保持活力的，保持活力的。MailSync正是这样做的。所以我认为这对社区来说是一件非常好的事情。所以我对所有这些感到非常兴奋。我认为电子邮件仍然是一个有很多低垂果实的领域。我的意思是，我在电子邮件上花了很多时间。你知道，有组织的电子邮件。我确实认为这有一定道理。这将开启人们可以编写新前端的领域。
ends and new mail experiences without having to learn, you know, 10 different protocols. Oh man, that's cool. Yeah. There are some email clients that are premium, like there's superhuman and there's hay, but I haven't really tried them yet. But yeah, there's got to be, I think, a better way to do email, like something that's suggested. Like, I don't want something that automatically puts things in different folders because you never really know what it's going to do. But something that somehow like just suggested ways for me to do email better. I think that could be cool.
无需学习十种不同的协议，就能实现邮件的收发和新体验。天哪，那太酷了。是的。有些邮件客户端是付费的，比如 Superhuman 和 Hay，但我还没真正试过。不过，我觉得肯定有一种更好的处理邮件的方式，比如某种建议功能。我不想要那种自动把邮件归类到不同文件夹的东西，因为你永远不知道它会做什么。但如果能以某种方式为我提供处理邮件的更好建议，我觉得那会很酷。
I mean, I was, I much preferred inbox, Google's Gmail client that they experimented with a while. I'm so still disappointed. I still feel I'm worse at email using the Gmail app than I was using inbox. I too still have a hole in my soul. Yeah. I actually switched. I, I, I found mail spring when inbox was shut down. Ah, okay. Well, we're not going to get on that. It's gonna make me sad. It's time for. Yeah, it's true. Inbox was so good, but it is what it is. Time for book of the show. All right. My book of the show, which actually, you know, maybe this might be the first time ever, but I already read this book. I'm not suggesting a book and walking someone off a plank. But yeah, this book is self-titled.
我的意思是，我更喜欢 Inbox，那是谷歌 Gmail 团队尝试过的一款客户端。我现在依然感到失望。我觉得用 Gmail 应用处理邮件比用 Inbox 时效率低多了。我也觉得心里空落落的。是的，我确实换了。Inbox 关闭时，我找到了 Mailspring。啊，好吧。我们还是别聊这个了，会让我难过的。是时候了。是的，确实。Inbox 太棒了，但事已至此。现在是本期推荐书目的时间。好的。我的推荐书目，这可能是第一次，但我已经读过这本书了。我不是在推荐一本书然后把人往火坑里推。这本书的书名就是它自己。
It's Elon Musk. And so it's all about Elon Musk. I think it's awesome. Actually, I found the book fascinating. I think that it really did a good job of you know covering the good and bad stuff actually it's really interesting the foreword is or maybe the first chapter preface or whatever whatever is um is from the author first person talking about um the negotiation he had to go through with elon to to write the book and originally elon wanted all these footnotes and you know i guess he's like
书名是《埃隆·马斯克传》，所以内容全是关于埃隆·马斯克的。我觉得它很棒。事实上，我觉得这本书非常引人入胜。我觉得它在涵盖好坏方面做得很好，真的很有趣。前言，或者第一章序言之类的，是作者以第一人称讲述了他为了写这本书与埃隆进行的谈判，最初埃隆想要所有的脚注，你知道，我猜他就像
he has a sort of engineer mindset where he wants to just correct the record and wants everything to compile right. But they kind of went back and forth on that a lot. But as you can imagine, someone like that's really concerned about their image and everything, right? That's not a surprise. But yeah, I felt like the book was extremely well balanced. It had a lot of really good detail. It covered all the, no pun intended, all different chapters in Elon Musk's life. So he started off as just an intern at some software company and then just doing a bunch of coding. One thing I noticed was, and one thing you kind of take for granted,
他有一种工程师思维，只想纠正记录，想让一切都编译正确。但他们在这方面来回拉锯了很多次。但你可以想象，像那样的人非常关心自己的形象，对吧？这并不奇怪。但我觉得这本书非常平衡。它有很多非常好的细节。它涵盖了埃隆·马斯克生活中的所有篇章，没有双关的意思。他最初只是一家软件公司的实习生，然后做了大量的编码工作。我注意到的一件事，也是你可能认为理所当然的一件事，
or at least I kind of took for granted, is the support that he received from his family. So there's a bit of trivia here. Elon Musk, one of his things he's known for is having kind of a rough childhood. His parents, I guess, were really strict. And I'm not taking anything away from that. But his parents actually funded the first company. And, and actually when I've read about other, uh, like tech billionaires, actually, you kind of see that pattern over and over again. And so I was thinking, it made me think a lot about, um, like, like that sort of community, like the Elon Musk's and the Mark Zuckerberg's and the Bill Gates and what have you. And a lot of these people are kind of like in a position where they can take some of those really big risks. So like, you know, someone in all of these cases, someone offered them millions of dollars for their company, and they turn them down. And I feel like that would be pretty extraordinary to do that. But then when you see the background, it's like, okay, well, actually these people already had millions of dollars usually like through their family. So,
或者至少我曾认为理所当然的，是他从家人那里得到的支持。这里有个小花絮。埃隆·马斯克出名的一点是他童年比较坎坷。我猜他的父母非常严厉。我并不是要否定这一点。但他的父母确实资助了他的第一家公司。实际上，当我读到其他科技亿万富翁时，你会一次又一次地看到这种模式。所以我一直在想，这让我思考了很多关于那种圈子，比如埃隆·马斯克、马克·扎克伯格、比尔·盖茨等等。这些人很多都处于一种可以承担巨大风险的位置。所以，你知道，在所有这些案例中，有人为他们的公司提供了数百万美元，而他们拒绝了。我觉得能做到这一点非常了不起。但当你看到背景时，你会发现，好吧，实际上这些人通常已经通过家庭拥有了数百万美元，所以，
so that, that kind of like made more sense, but still, I mean, the, the, you know, Elon Musk's a total genius. Uh, I felt like, uh, yeah, I have a ton of respect for him after reading the book. And, uh, um, yeah, I thought it was a fantastic read. It actually is very exciting. I was really interested in it the whole time. So it doesn't, you know, a lot of these can tend to drag on because they might say, well, here's sort of the middle years where nothing happened. And there really wasn't a lot of that. The book was super entertaining all the way through. Nice. I've actually not read any Elon Musk's biography. I not too much studied him as a person yeah you know i i it's uh i know very little also about a lot of i don't really study a lot of people but for some reason like i was really just drawn to reading this biography the only other biography i've read is the steve jobs biography and uh yeah there's there's just a lot of really interesting parallels parallels there and uh yeah it's a solid book nice my book of the show is ready player two
所以这在某种程度上说得通，但即便如此，埃隆·马斯克绝对是个天才。我觉得，是的，读完这本书后我对他充满了敬意。而且，是的，我觉得这是一本非常棒的书。它实际上非常令人兴奋。我全程都对它很感兴趣。所以它不会，你知道，很多这类书往往会拖沓，因为他们可能会说，这是中间几年，什么都没发生。而这本书里真的没有多少那种内容。这本书从头到尾都超级有趣。不错。我其实还没读过任何关于埃隆·马斯克的传记。我没有太深入研究过他这个人。是的，你知道，我也对很多人了解甚少，我其实并不怎么研究很多人，但出于某种原因，我真的被吸引去读这本传记了。我读过的唯一另一本传记是史蒂夫·乔布斯的传记，而且，是的，那里有很多非常有趣的相似之处，而且，是的，这是一本扎实的好书。不错，我的推荐书目是《头号玩家 2》。
this is the follow-up to ready player one um by ernest klein uh it's set in the same universe as ready player one i guess it's a low-hanging low-hanging fruit not a super deep book but enjoyable i enjoyed as much as ready player one but definitely pretty solid i i'm not getting through as many books uh nowadays as i used to yep same here but definitely pretty solid. I'm not getting through as many books nowadays as I used to. Yep, same here. But this one was nice, easy. I actually listened to it, but a nice, easy listen. And I kind of did it in the background. I thought it was good. You know, the same kind of thing. If you liked the first one, you probably like the second one. If you didn't like the first one, I wouldn't bother with the second one. Yeah, I mean, it's the same kind of like pop culture laden,
这是恩斯特·克莱恩所著《头号玩家》的续集。它设定在与《头号玩家》相同的宇宙中。我想这属于低垂的果实，不是一本特别深奥的书，但很愉快。我像喜欢《头号玩家》一样喜欢它，但绝对相当扎实。我现在读的书不像以前那么多了。是的，我也是。但这本书很好，很轻松。我其实是听的，但听起来很轻松。我是在后台听的。我觉得它很好。你知道，同样的情况。如果你喜欢第一部，你可能也会喜欢第二部。如果你不喜欢第一部，我就不会费心去读第二部了。是的，我的意思是，它同样充满了流行文化，
you know, exploration of the 80s and a little bit more music bent maybe than the first one. But yeah, a good read. I always struggle. I, you know, don't unlike a biography, I don't want to spoil the fiction too much. So I don't really want to say too much about what the book is. But yeah, Ready Player Two by Ernest Cline. Cool. Yeah, you recommended the first one a while back, and I gave it a read and I thought it was fabulous. So yeah, I'll definitely I think I already bought this book as soon as I saw it, but I haven't read it yet. Yeah, my backlog is getting pretty big. So I got to start spending some dedicated time getting through all these books I want to read. Yeah, I noticed that I've kind of caught myself switching to podcasts because, you know,
你知道，对 80 年代的探索，可能比第一部多了一点音乐元素。但确实是一本好书。我总是很纠结。不像传记，我不想剧透太多小说内容。所以我真的不想说太多关于这本书的内容。但确实，《头号玩家 2》，作者恩斯特·克莱恩。酷。是的，你很久以前推荐过第一部，我读了，觉得棒极了。所以，是的，我肯定，我想我一看到这本书就买了，但我还没读。是的，我的待读书单越来越长了。所以我得开始花专门的时间来读完所有我想读的书。是的，我注意到我有点转向播客了，因为，你知道，
I don't have the long commute or anything. And so but I think I'm going to try to get back into, you know, doing full books, but just in bite sized pieces and see how that works out. Is it time for tool of the show? Tool of the show. My tool of the show is Datadog, which is an amazing tool. It is super, super fun. So the way Datadog works is, so you're developing, let's say, some kind of app. It could be an Android app, could be a website with some web backend, or even on the front end on the browser.
我没有长途通勤之类的。所以，但我认为我会尝试重新开始，你知道，阅读完整的书，但以小块的形式，看看效果如何。是时候介绍本期工具了吗？本期工具。我的本期工具是 Datadog，这是一个了不起的工具。它超级超级有趣。Datadog 的工作方式是，假设你正在开发某种应用。它可以是安卓应用，可以是带有 Web 后端的网站，甚至可以是浏览器上的前端。
Anything you develop, you're going to give it to somebody. And that person is going to run it when you're not around. And so a bunch of logs are going to be generated, right? Now, like if it crashes, that's a whole nother thing. And I think I already mentioned Sentry in a previous episode. So if it crashes, you know, you have Breakpad, you have Crashpad, you have Sentry, you have a million different tools, Rollbar, etc. But then there's also just, is this healthy? In general, you don't want to crash websites or apps, right? But you still want to know, for example, how many people are opening your app, clicking on, let's say, the settings and then leaving the whole app? Well, that would probably be good to know.
你开发的任何东西，你都会交给别人。而那个人会在你不在的时候运行它。于是就会生成一堆日志，对吧？现在，如果它崩溃了，那是另一回事。我想我在上一集已经提到过 Sentry 了。所以如果它崩溃了，你知道，你有 Breakpad，有 Crashpad，有 Sentry，有一百万种不同的工具，Rollbar 等等。但还有一点，就是它是否健康？通常，你不想让网站或应用崩溃，对吧？但你仍然想知道，例如，有多少人在打开你的应用，点击了设置，然后离开了整个应用？嗯，知道这些可能很好。
Or just anytime you have any type of log, like sometimes you have a log, you know, should never get here. Right. And it, and it fires. Right. So most apps, sites, et cetera, are generating logs. And, you know, it's great to have those sort of aggregated. And so a data dog does is they have a bunch of clients for a whole bunch of different languages. I actually ended up writing my own client because they didn't have a C++ with your application ID and a bunch of logs. And then what Datadog does is it collects all of that. And then it presents you with this really nice web UI where you can, you can actually, there's something called live tail and you can actually see logs as they come in. And then you can write rules. And they actually have this sort of way to automatically find patterns in your logs. So if you have a bunch of logs that says, you know, received 26 packets, received 31 packets, received 100 packets, right,
或者仅仅是当你有了任何类型的日志时，比如有时你有一个日志，你知道，永远不应该到达这里。对吧。然后它触发了。对吧。所以大多数应用、网站等都在生成日志。而且，你知道，把它们聚合起来是很棒的。所以 Datadog 所做的是，他们为各种不同的语言提供了许多客户端。我实际上最终编写了自己的客户端，因为他们没有 C++ 客户端，带有你的应用 ID 和一堆日志。然后 Datadog 所做的是收集所有这些。然后它为你呈现一个非常漂亮的 Web UI，你可以在那里，实际上，有一种东西叫实时尾随（live tail），你可以实时看到日志。然后你可以编写规则。他们实际上有一种自动查找日志模式的方法。所以如果你有一堆日志说，你知道，收到 26 个数据包，收到 31 个数据包，收到 100 个数据包，对吧，
all of those lines are going to be different, but they all have the same pattern. It's just received, you know, N packets. Datadog will automatically pull out that pattern and then group all of those logs together. To be honest, I haven't ever used any of the premium features. I've only ever used the free tier, which makes me think that they probably should maybe charge more or something, but nothing I've talked about costs any money. They do all of this for free. And then you can then write rules on top of that. So you can say, for example, all the logs that have the severity level of error, I want all of those to get written to an S3 bucket. So S3 is the Amazon AWS file system.
所有这些行都会不同，但它们都有相同的模式。只是收到，你知道，N 个数据包。Datadog 会自动提取该模式，然后将所有这些日志分组在一起。老实说，我从来没有使用过任何高级功能。我只用过免费层级，这让我觉得他们可能应该多收点钱什么的，但我谈到的任何东西都不花钱。他们免费提供所有这些。然后你可以在此基础上编写规则。所以你可以说，例如，所有严重级别为错误的日志，我希望所有这些都被写入 S3 存储桶。所以 S3 是亚马逊 AWS 的文件系统。
And so that's one of the rules I have set up. So whenever an error log happens on Eternal Terminal, I've actually gone through and looked at all the error logs to make sure that there's nothing personal, like someone's name or IP address or anything like that. And so I know all these error logs are safe. And then whenever one of those error logs are written, it will get sent to Datadog and
这就是我设置的规则之一。所以每当 Eternal Terminal 发生错误日志时，我实际上已经检查过所有错误日志，以确保没有个人信息，比如某人的名字或 IP 地址之类的。所以我知道所有这些错误日志都是安全的。然后每当其中一个错误日志被写入时，它就会被发送到 Datadog，
then it gets dumped through an S3 bucket. So all of that is super nice. The other part of it is Datadog, as I was saying, kind of alluding to earlier, they're using your own kind of infrastructure. So like Datadog's not actually storing anything. They have a way where you give them permission to a folder on your AWS. And so you're, you know, effectively you're paying for all the hosting costs and stuff yourself. And because of that, there's no limits.
然后它会被转储到 S3 存储桶中。所以所有这些都超级好。它的另一部分是 Datadog，正如我刚才提到的，他们使用的是你自己的基础设施。所以 Datadog 实际上并没有存储任何东西。他们有一种方式，你给他们权限访问你 AWS 上的一个文件夹。所以你，你知道，实际上你自己支付了所有的托管费用之类的。正因为如此，没有限制。
Like they can just take tons and tons of data. And if they have to write a lot of data, you're going to pay for it through Amazon, not through them. So it's an amazing service for free. I have to look up what the, I think for premium, they'll let you do alerts and more fancy things. But yeah, definitely check that out if you're building anything that's going to be looked at by other people. Super cool. Yeah, they're like a publicly traded company and stuff now, right? That's a good question. I don't know. This is super cool to like hear you say like kind of like their niche on top of other people's services, I guess is kind of cool. Yeah, actually, that was I felt like a really good sort of business decision, because in my case, you know, it's a it's an open source project.
就像他们可以接收海量的数据。如果他们必须写入大量数据，你将通过亚马逊支付，而不是通过他们。所以这是一个免费的惊人服务。我得查一下，我想对于高级版，他们会让你进行警报和更花哨的事情。但是的，如果你正在构建任何会被其他人查看的东西，一定要看看它。超级酷。是的，他们现在是一家上市公司之类的，对吧？这是个好问题。我不知道。听到你这样说，比如他们在别人服务之上的利基市场，这真的很酷。是的，实际上，我觉得这是一个非常好的商业决策，因为在我的案例中，你知道，这是一个开源项目。
I'm not too worried about if they get hacked, these sort of error logs, which, as I said, have no personal real data on them. But, you know, imagine you're like a company that's logging customer information or whatever. The fact that, you know, it's passing through their system briefly and then it's gone is kind of nice from a security standpoint. And it means for them they don't really have a big footprint. My tool of the show is uh already teased it not a tool but a game i expect you to die uh for i played it on the quest 2 but i believe it's actually on a lot of vr platforms so real quick the data dog is publicly traded and actually that company is has a market cap of 28 billion billion. So that is a much, I kind of, I thought it was
我不担心如果他们被黑客攻击，这些错误日志，正如我所说，上面没有任何个人真实数据。但是，你知道，想象一下你是一家记录客户信息等的公司。事实上，你知道，它短暂地通过了他们的系统然后就消失了，从安全角度来看是很好的。这意味着对他们来说，他们并没有真正大的足迹。我的本期工具是，呃，之前已经预告过了，不是工具，是一个游戏，《I Expect You to Die》。我是在 Quest 2 上玩的，但我相信它实际上在很多 VR 平台上都有。顺便说一下，Datadog 是上市公司，实际上那家公司的市值是 280 亿。所以，我有点，我以为它
just a small company, I guess I was totally off the mark there. But I think if you're going to buy a Dogecoin instead, buy a share of Datadog. That's my advice. Shares are a million dollars piece um so my game is i expect you to die i guess it's a little bit like a escape room kind of feel you unlike the ones i was saying where you move around the room here you're actually supposed to be sort of seated but all of the scenarios make sense with you being stationary so either you're like sitting or standing in kind of one spot and moving your body sort of like rotating around the room to do various items and there's various puzzles and it's themed as you're sort of a spy going on missions but there's not a ton of explanation and various things that you do in trying to to solve the puzzles cause you to die. So you may be like in a car and there's poison gas outside. And if you break the window somehow,
只是一个小公司，我想我完全搞错了。但我觉得如果你要买狗狗币，不如买一股 Datadog。这是我的建议。股票每股一百万美元，所以我的游戏是《I Expect You to Die》，我想它有点像密室逃脱的感觉。不像我刚才说的那些你可以在房间里走动的游戏，这里你实际上应该是坐着的，但所有的场景都让你保持静止，所以你要么坐着，要么站在一个地方，移动你的身体，比如在房间里旋转来处理各种物品，有各种谜题，主题是你作为一个间谍去执行任务，但没有太多的解释，你在尝试解决谜题时做的各种事情会导致你死亡。所以你可能在车里，外面有毒气。如果你以某种方式打破窗户，
the poison gas is going to come in and kill you. But that's not the only way there might be a grenade. And if you drop the handle off the grenade, the grenade will explode. And so you aren't expected, at least I guess based on the title, I assume you're not expected to not to die. So you die and then you try again and and you you sort of figure out the puzzles uh puzzle rooms isn't
毒气就会进来杀死你。但这并不是唯一的方法，可能还有一颗手榴弹。如果你把手榴弹的拉环拔掉，手榴弹就会爆炸。所以你并不被期望，至少根据标题，我假设你不被期望不死亡。所以你死了，然后你再试一次，你，你，你弄清楚了谜题，呃，谜题房间不是
interesting i've never done an actual puzzle room like in real life like i've never gone to one oh my family loves them they're so fun like escape rooms you mean oh that's what i mean yeah sorry i don't even know the name i don't't, this is not my... Oh, they are so good. But I sense it's probably something similar where there's a kind of language to them that you have to figure out. Like if you just went to one never having heard of it before, you're not going to necessarily do so well because you don't, the premise can be,
很有趣，我从来没有在现实生活中做过真正的密室逃脱，我从来没去过。哦，我的家人很喜欢它们，它们太有趣了。你是说密室逃脱吗？哦，我就是那个意思，是的，抱歉，我甚至不知道名字，这不是我的……哦，它们太棒了。但我感觉到它可能和某种东西类似，它们有一种你需要弄清楚的语言。就像如果你从来没听说过就去玩一个，你未必会做得很好，因为你不知道，前提可以是，
you may need to know a certain trope or a certain way of thinking for it to start to make sense. The same is true of a lot of things. So I feel this one does a good balance of understanding where the puzzle is. So sometimes when I play games that are claimed to be sort of escape room themed, I don't even, I can't figure out where the puzzle is. I understand I'm supposed to do something, but I don't get that you're supposed to just tap around the screen or you're supposed to bash open things
你可能需要知道某种套路或某种思维方式才能开始理解。很多事情都是如此。所以我感觉这个游戏在理解谜题在哪里方面做得很好。所以有时当我玩那些声称是密室逃脱主题的游戏时，我甚至，我找不到谜题在哪里。我知道我应该做点什么，但我不知道你是应该点击屏幕周围，还是应该砸开东西
to look what's inside. Those aren't intuitive to me. But this game, I feel like, strikes a really nice balance of like, it's clear what things I can affect. And then by like working through the interactions between them, I can see where the puzzle is and I can see how to solve the puzzle.
来看看里面有什么。这些对我来说不直观。但这个游戏，我觉得，在什么东西我可以影响方面达到了很好的平衡。然后通过处理它们之间的交互，我可以看出谜题在哪里，我也可以看出如何解决谜题。
I don't always get it right the first time, but each time I can continue to make progress. And so I find it for my naive level of sophistication. I don't have to like go consult a walkthrough repeatedly to like keep making progress. I'm able to work it through on my own. And it's at just the right difficulty level where I don't get bored of it. And I don't just cruise right through it either. So I very much enjoyed and the theming is kind of cool to a little bit James Bondy a little bit, you know, the spy thing. And it has a little bit of story without being too much I find to be a really good experience. And each level is sort
我并不总是第一次就做对，但每次我都能继续取得进展。所以我发现对于我这种天真的复杂程度来说，我不需要反复查阅攻略来保持进展。我能够自己解决它。而且它的难度恰到好处，我不会对它感到厌烦。我也不会直接轻松通关。所以我非常喜欢，而且主题有点酷，有点詹姆斯·邦德的感觉，有点，你知道，间谍的感觉。它有一点故事，但又不会太多，我觉得这是一个非常好的体验。而且每个关卡都
of bite sized enough that for me, like sitting and doing one VR session, you know, I can get through kind of like one level and that's about the right for me. Cool and doing one vr session you know i can get through kind of like one level and that's about the right for me cool it makes sense and so yeah i guess one of the challenges with that i mean puzzle games in general it's like uh you never really know as a puzzle game designer like how you're supposed to deal with someone not figuring it out that seems like the hardest part right like with these rooms, what they've done is, like for example, we did one where, and we've done a bunch,
足够小，对我来说，坐下来进行一次 VR 会话，你知道，我可以通关一个关卡，这对我来说刚刚好。酷，进行一次 VR 会话，你知道，我可以通关一个关卡，这对我来说刚刚好。酷，这说得通。所以，是的，我想这其中的挑战之一，我的意思是谜题游戏通常是，就像，呃，作为一个谜题游戏设计师，你永远不知道该如何处理某人弄不明白的情况，这似乎是最难的部分，对吧？就像这些房间，他们所做的是，例如，我们做了一个，而且我们做了很多，
but we did one where we just, there was just a trick that we didn't get. I think it was some kind of language trick where there was like four different cat names and based on the cat names, that was the clue. Like you just had to know some factoid that none of us had really heard of. And so we were really stuck.
但我们做了一个，我们只是，有一个技巧我们没弄明白。我想那是一种语言技巧，有四个不同的猫的名字，根据猫的名字，那是线索。就像你必须知道一些我们都没听说过的冷知识。所以我们真的卡住了。
And so they have this thing where you can press a button and basically they'll kind of give you, I think there's two levels of hints. But yeah, kind of getting that right, I think especially for VR, it's really important because you don't want to take the headset off and then go look on Wikipedia andipedia back you know and so uh actually how do you die in in these games like does the screen just go black yeah i think it
所以他们有一个东西，你可以按一个按钮，基本上他们会给你，我想有两个级别的提示。但是的，把这一点做好，我觉得特别是对于 VR 来说，真的很重要，因为你不想摘下头显，然后去维基百科查，你知道，所以，呃，实际上你在这些游戏中是怎么死的？屏幕会变黑吗？是的，我想它
like i don't remember exactly i think believe that like fades to red you know and then it's just like but whatever when it happens like a explosion of a grenade or like gas coming in and you starting to like black out and you have a few seconds to rack because sometimes you can stop it but sometimes like a grenade exploding you can't um and then it fades right and you go to like a sort of death screen where it you know makes some funny quip about you sucking and not figuring it out or so much wasted training on you or you know some some such something and then you can replay the level but there are achievements as well and the achievements sometimes require you to die in certain ways or whatever. Oh, yeah, that makes sense.
就像，我不记得确切了，我想它会淡出成红色，你知道，然后就像，但无论发生什么，当它发生时，比如手榴弹爆炸或气体进来，你开始昏迷，你有几秒钟的时间反应，因为有时你可以阻止它，但有时像手榴弹爆炸你无法阻止，然后它就淡出了，你进入一个死亡屏幕，它，你知道，说一些关于你很烂、没弄明白的俏皮话，或者在你身上浪费了太多训练，或者你知道，诸如此类的事情，然后你可以重玩这个关卡，但也有成就，成就有时要求你以特定的方式死亡等等。哦，是的，这说得通。
Yeah, I used to play a game when I was really little called Lost Vikings, which was a puzzle game. And one thing that I thought was pretty interesting was if you lost, if like you died three times trying to finish the level, then on the fourth time they would offer you to skip it. Oh. then on the fourth time they would offer you to skip it and uh oh yeah i feel like that that actually is probably the hardest part of all these games is figuring out what to do there they do that in some super mario games like the newer ones if you die too many times they give you like a special power up or whatever that that makes it a little easier yep yep that makes sense um but yeah i so i've really enjoyed it you know, I think I want to get more into these puzzle games, but like you pointed out,
是的，我小时候玩过一个游戏叫《失落的维京人》，那是一个谜题游戏。我想到的一件很有趣的事情是，如果你输了，如果你为了完成关卡死了三次，那么第四次他们会让你跳过它。哦，第四次他们会让你跳过它，呃，哦，是的，我觉得这实际上可能是所有这些游戏中最难的部分，弄清楚该做什么。他们在一些超级马里奥游戏中也这样做，像较新的那些，如果你死得太多次，他们会给你一个特殊的强化道具之类的，让它变得容易一点。是的，是的，这说得通。呃，但是的，我真的很喜欢它，你知道，我想我想要更多地接触这些谜题游戏，但就像你指出的那样，
they need to be kind of like well-designed or else it just becomes frustrating. I still find myself frustrated at some of the puzzle games where you need to like do an action repeatedly, even though it's not resulting in anything happening. Like, oh, you click this character and the character burps and you have to kick the character and they just keep burping in exactly the same way.
它们需要设计得很好，否则只会变得令人沮丧。我仍然发现自己在某些谜题游戏中感到沮丧，因为你需要反复执行一个动作，即使它没有任何结果。比如，哦，你点击这个角色，角色打嗝，你必须踢这个角色，他们只是以完全相同的方式继续打嗝。
But on the 13th burp, they belch out a potion in their belch bubble or something. And it's like, what? Like, why would I sit here and click the same thing, getting the same result? If you don't give me some indication that progression is being made, I'm going to go do something else. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Like there should be a way to just using logic and observations to not have to guess. I think that's that's really important. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Actually, they I used to do the those would you'd guess but it would just take forever or like Sudoku. So because much more common example, like you shouldn't be doing a lot of guessing in Sudoku. Like if you're doing a lot of guessing, no, no guessing. Properly designed Sudoku puzzle requires zero guessing. I thought there were some were like there would be maybe
但在第 13 次打嗝时，他们在打嗝泡泡里吐出了一瓶药水之类的。这就像，什么？就像，我为什么要坐在这里点击同样的东西，得到同样的结果？如果你不给我任何进展的迹象，我就去做别的事了。是的，是的，完全正确。就像应该有一种方法，只使用逻辑和观察，而不必猜测。我觉得这真的很重要。是的。是的。是的。实际上，他们，我过去常做那些，你会猜测，但这会花很长时间，或者像数独。所以因为更常见的例子，你不应该在数独中做大量的猜测。就像如果你在做大量的猜测，不，不猜测。设计得当的数独谜题需要零猜测。我以为有些谜题会有，比如会有
one guess. It may need a very advanced technique or whatever, right? Like if it's a hard puzzle, like you may not know the deduction method that's needed and therefore you would have to guess if it's like above your level but uh like a any like now i don't want to say like you can make whatever sudoku puzzle you want right as long as if it has a unique solution and it could require guessing though but they're like when the algorithms design them they or the designers design them they're supposed to know here's the only kind of techniques you know and it should be forward solvable using only deduction oh interesting yeah that makes a lot of sense i think uh i think yeah there was this other puzzle game i used to really enjoy
一个猜测。它可能需要非常高级的技巧之类的，对吧？就像如果这是一个难题，你可能不知道所需的推导方法，因此如果它高于你的水平，你将不得不猜测，但，呃，就像任何，现在我不想说，你可以制作任何你想要的数独谜题，对吧？只要它有一个唯一的解，它可能需要猜测，但它们就像，当算法设计它们时，它们或者设计师设计它们时，他们应该知道，这里只有你知道的技巧，而且它应该只使用推导就能向前求解。哦，有趣，是的，这很有道理。我想，呃，我想，是的，还有另一个我过去非常喜欢的谜题游戏，
and um i i watched a um actually a podcast. There's a podcast called Game Design. I can't remember the exact name of it. It was Game Design Podcast. And one of the inventors, the person who wrote that game was on that podcast. And it's actually really clever. They just kind of, and Sudoku probably works somewhat similar,
而且，呃，我看了，呃，实际上是一个播客。有一个播客叫《游戏设计》。我不记得确切的名字了。那是《游戏设计播客》。其中一位发明者，写那个游戏的人就在那个播客上。而且它实际上非常聪明。他们只是，你知道，数独可能工作方式类似，
is it kind of worked backwards from the answer. But you have to work backwards in a way where it's not ambiguous. But yeah, I think that sounds awesome. awesome actually i'll give that a shot i'm looking for another quest game to pick up yeah um this is one where like i pretty much like the kids will play a level i've already played and once they learn like you know kind of thing but it's over their head but they enjoy watching me die like oh daddy sometimes i do it on purpose sometimes like i realize there's a novel way to die and i'll let myself die just for kicks.
它是从答案反向工作的。但你必须以一种不模棱两可的方式反向工作。但是的，我觉得这听起来很棒。很棒，实际上我会试一试，我正在寻找另一个 Quest 游戏来玩。是的，呃，这是一个，就像，我基本上，孩子们会玩我已经玩过的关卡，一旦他们学会了，你知道，那种东西，但这对他们来说太难了，但他们喜欢看我死，就像，哦，爸爸，有时我是故意的，有时我意识到有一种新奇的死法，我会为了好玩让自己死。
But they always think it's hilarious. Oh, daddy, you suck. Like you can't, like you didn't realize that grenade was going to kill you. Like how dumb are you? No, I mean, I'm being hyperbolic, but it's an enjoyable family experience that way. Yeah, my son does the same thing with me and Zelda.
但他们总是觉得这很搞笑。哦，爸爸，你真烂。就像你不能，就像你没意识到那颗手榴弹会杀死你。你有多笨？不，我的意思是，我是在夸张，但这是一种有趣的家庭体验。是的，我儿子在玩《塞尔达》时也对我做同样的事。
So he, I made it to this one temple in Zelda where it really was too advanced it's one of these ones you have to battle a robot people have played the breath of the wild there's some of these temples where you fight battles but the game is non-linear so you could get there at any point and this one robot i just ended up basically if he hit me at all i just died instantly and so it made it made this battle way harder than it really needed to be by doing it so early. And yeah, my son actually was filming it on his iPad for his school share day. And he's like, dad's going to die again. He's going to die. Watch. He's going to die. And then I died.
所以他，我到了《塞尔达》里的一个神庙，那里确实太高级了，这是那种你必须与机器人战斗的神庙之一，玩过《旷野之息》的人都知道，有一些神庙你需要进行战斗，但游戏是非线性的，所以你可以在任何时候到达那里，这个机器人，我基本上如果他打我一下，我就立刻死了，所以通过这么早做这件事，让这场战斗比它真正需要的难得多。而且，是的，我儿子实际上正在用他的 iPad 拍摄它，为了他的学校分享日。他说，爸爸又要死了。他要死了。看。他要死了。然后我就死了。
He's like, yep, dad died again. There's a game over screen. I was like, honestly, it's the first time in probably 25 years where I wanted to throw the controller for 35 years or something. But I was like, you know, having the audience support actually didn't help that much. All right. Hash maps. Hash maps. Yeah, I'm going to kick it off.
他说，是的，爸爸又死了。有一个游戏结束画面。我当时想，老实说，这是我大概 25 年来第一次想扔掉手柄，或者 35 年之类的。但我当时想，你知道，有观众支持实际上并没有太大帮助。好的。哈希映射。哈希映射。是的，我要开始了。
So, you know, before, you know, when I was in college and learning about data structure and algorithms, of course, I learned about, you know, Hashmaps. And, you know, oh, cool. Like, we're going to talk about, you know, what makes them interesting in a minute. But it never really clicked to me. And I was mentioning this to Jason in the pre-show. I don't think we'll get to it at the end because we're already going along. But when I went to start, you know, looking at sort of what you call Silicon Valley companies, big companies, like interviewing there, like I kept reading, oh, HashMaps, you got no HashMaps, you got no, I hadn't really used HashMaps.
所以，你知道，以前，你知道，当我在大学里学习数据结构和算法时，当然，我学习了，你知道，哈希映射。而且，你知道，哦，酷。就像，我们一会儿要谈谈，你知道，是什么让它们变得有趣。但我从来没有真正理解它。我之前在预演中向 Jason 提到过这一点。我不认为我们最后能讲到它，因为我们已经讲了很久了。但当我开始，你知道，寻找所谓的硅谷公司，大公司，比如在那里面试时，我一直在读，哦，哈希映射，你必须知道哈希映射，你必须，我还没真正用过哈希映射。
And I thought they were overplaying it. But sure enough, all my interviews, like some solutions needed familiarity with HashMaps and intricacies of HashMaps. And then showing up to, you know, my first jobs there, like, sure enough, like hash maps were like super common. When you get to kind of like really big data, I was really surprised I underestimated the importance of hash maps early in my computer science career. Yep, same here. So the promise of a hash map is insertion and lookup being constant time
我以为他们夸大了。但果然，我所有的面试，比如一些解决方案需要熟悉哈希映射和哈希映射的复杂性。然后出现在，你知道，我在那里的第一份工作，果然，哈希映射超级常见。当你接触到，你知道，真正的大数据时，我真的很惊讶，我低估了哈希映射在我计算机科学职业生涯早期的重要性。是的，我也是。所以哈希映射的承诺是插入和查找是常数时间。
so the idea is if you think of like a binary tree we talked about trees i think in our last duo episode then you get log of in insertion right the insertion if you just insert into a sorted array for instance uh you and you don't use binary search, you'd have to sort of like go through each element in the array to find where you need to insert it. So that would be like linear time. If your stuff is a well-formed binary tree, then you need log of in like visits to nodes before you find where to insert.
所以想法是，如果你想到像二叉树，我想我们在上一期双人节目中谈到了树，那么你得到 log n 的插入，对吧？插入，如果你只是插入到一个排序数组中，例如，呃，你没有使用二分搜索，你必须，你知道，遍历数组中的每个元素来找到你需要插入它的地方。所以那将是线性时间。如果你的东西是一个结构良好的二叉树，那么你需要 log n 次访问节点，然后才能找到插入的地方。
But HashMaps promised to blow that away by saying, I'll give you a constant time insertion and a constant time lookup. So if you're trying to see if this key is in your HashMap, you can do that in sort of constant time. That doesn't mean zero time. It just means that it doesn't really matter how many items are in your map, that no matter how big your map
但哈希映射承诺通过说，我给你常数时间插入和常数时间查找来彻底改变这一点。所以如果你试图查看这个键是否在你的哈希映射中，你可以在常数时间内做到这一点。这并不意味着零时间。它只是意味着，无论你的映射中有多少项，无论你的映射有多大，
grows within bounds, you would still get sort of this algorithmic constant time. And so that's a super, super powerful thing. And we're going to talk a little bit about the various ways that can be accomplished. Cool. Yeah, totally makes sense. Yeah, I think, I think it actually will surprise a lot of people, like how ubiquitous hash functions are, they're really just everywhere. But But yeah, at a high level, what's going on here is, so you know, we talked about trees, right? And, you know, trees are super nice. The challenges with trees are that you have to, you know, keep them balanced, right? And so that could be really expensive. And even if you don't have to keep them balanced, putting something or finding something in a tree takes logarithmic time. And so that doesn't sound like a big deal, but when you start putting lots and lots of things into the database,
在范围内增长，你仍然会得到这种算法上的常数时间。所以这是一个超级超级强大的东西。我们将谈谈可以实现这一点的各种方法。酷。是的，完全有道理。是的，我想，我想这实际上会让很多人感到惊讶，你知道哈希函数是多么无处不在，它们真的无处不在。但，但是的，在高层面上，这里发生的是，所以你知道，我们谈到了树，对吧？而且，你知道，树超级好。树的挑战在于你必须，你知道，保持它们平衡，对吧？所以这可能非常昂贵。即使你不必保持它们平衡，在树中放入东西或找到东西也需要对数时间。所以这听起来不是什么大不了的事，但当你开始把大量的东西放入数据库时，
it can actually become a really big problem, right? So imagine like log base two of of a million is oh geez i kind of uh kind of put myself on the spot here is what like maybe six or something or the log base you know log base two of a million is what like 14 or something anyways it could easily end up taking like 14 times as long the internet says says it's 20. Oh, 20. Well, there you go. All right. It shows how well I could do a log in my head. But yeah. And so imagine, you know, like you have an app and now it takes 20 times as long to run. It could be, it could end up being a really big deal. And so the challenge with hashing is figuring out sort of the hash function. And what that means is figuring out
它实际上可能成为一个非常大的问题，对吧？所以想象一下，比如 log 以 2 为底的 100 万是，哦，天哪，我有点，呃，有点让自己陷入困境了，是多少，比如 6 还是什么，或者 log 以，你知道，log 以 2 为底的 100 万是多少，比如 14 还是什么，无论如何，它很容易最终花费 14 倍的时间。互联网说它是 20。哦，20。好吧，给你。好的。这显示了我在脑子里做对数的能力。但是的。所以想象一下，你知道，比如你有一个应用，现在它运行需要 20 倍的时间。它可能，它最终可能成为一个非常大的问题。所以哈希的挑战是弄清楚，你知道，哈希函数。这意味着弄清楚
sort of some type of way to represent something really concisely or really like ultimately represented with just a number. And so there's been a bunch of work in this field. I mean, it would take a really long time for us to really dive deep into it. But at a high level,
某种方式来非常简洁地表示某物，或者真的，最终只用一个数字来表示它。所以在这个领域已经做了很多工作。我的意思是，我们要真正深入研究它需要很长时间。但在高层面上，
there's really two types of hash functions that are important. The first type is like cryptographically secure, and the second is not secure, right? So for example, if you're trying to hash like credit card numbers, well, maybe, like maybe, you know, someone, let's say someone has a, like has a person's name, they're trying to find their credit card number, and maybe they have somehow they have some access to the database. And so they have all these hashed credit card numbers. If you do something that's not cryptographically secure, then, you know, they can use various statistical tricks to try to reverse engineer that. Or maybe they can narrow down. If they have a list of credit card numbers,
确实有两种重要的哈希函数。第一种是加密安全的，第二种是不安全的，对吧？所以例如，如果你试图哈希像信用卡号码，嗯，也许，比如，你知道，某人，假设某人有一个，比如有一个人的名字，他们试图找到他们的信用卡号码，也许他们以某种方式对数据库有访问权限。所以他们有所有这些哈希过的信用卡号码。如果你做了一些不是加密安全的事情，那么，你知道，他们可以使用各种统计技巧来尝试反向工程。或者也许他们可以缩小范围。如果他们有一份信用卡号码列表，
they can narrow down which one it is. And so if you're storing something really sensitive, using a cryptographically secure one has some nice guarantees, right? Or if speed is not super, super critical. And so that's why something like Git, for example, Git will use SHA-256, which is cryptographically secure. Now, you might not be storing passwords in Git. In fact, you probably should never be storing passwords in Git. But they do that because it's on almost all the computers and that's not the thing that's going to slow you down if you're using Git. You're not blocked by the hash. Jason, there's one more point there too that I was kind of unaware of because I don't build these kinds of services. But another reason to make
他们可以缩小它是哪一个。所以如果你正在存储非常敏感的东西，使用加密安全的哈希有一些很好的保证，对吧？或者如果速度不是超级超级关键。这就是为什么像 Git 这样的东西，例如，Git 会使用 SHA-256，它是加密安全的。现在，你可能不会在 Git 中存储密码。事实上，你可能永远不应该在 Git 中存储密码。但他们这样做是因为它几乎在所有的计算机上，而且如果你正在使用 Git，那不是会让你慢下来的东西。你不会被哈希阻塞。Jason，那里还有一点我不太了解，因为我不构建这类服务。但确保使用加密哈希的另一个原因是，如果你以某种方式拥有一个公共服务或一个 API，它不仅仅是受信任的用户，我猜，它是由哈希映射支持的，并且键以某种方式是用户定义的。所以我正在创建一个用户名，或者我正在创建一些我可以控制的东西，如果有人能推断出你正在使用什么哈希函数并插入条目，所有这些条目都会冲突，都指向同一个哈希，那么他们基本上可以导致拒绝服务。我们一会儿会谈谈为什么。但这就是为什么如果你有某种性质的公共 API，你打算用哈希来支持它，你想要非常小心，以免有人能强制发生哈希冲突，从而像减慢拒绝服务你的服务。是的，是的，
sure to use cryptographic hashes is if you have sort of a public service in some way or an API that isn't only trusted users, I guess, that is backed by a hash map and the keys in some way are like basically user defined. So I'm creating a username or I'm creating something that I can kind of control and if someone can deduce what hash function you're using and insert entries which all collide, all go to the same hash, then they can basically cause a denial of service. We'll talk about why in sort of a minute. But that's another reason why if you have a public API of some nature, where you're going to back it by a hash, you want to be really careful that someone can't cause like force hash collisions to occur, and thereby like slower denial of service your your service. Yeah, yeah,
这说得通。是的，我想，是的。所以，所以只是，是的。使用 Git 是一个很好的例子。所以，假设某人，呃，你知道，创建了 1000 万个 Git 提交，它们都有相同的内容。对吧。好吧，而你正在运行一个 Git，呃，网站，就像你，你，你作为工作在为其他人托管 Git。对吧。所以你可能会写一些规则说，看，如果这个人，你知道，多次进行相同的提交，你知道，它们都有相同的内容，那么我会阻止他们，或者，你知道，我会，是的，阻止他们，然后发送一封电子邮件说，你知道，你的账户已被入侵之类的。
that makes sense. Yeah, I think, yeah. So, so just, yeah. Using Git is a good example. Like, so let's say someone, um, you know, creates like 10 million Git commits that all have the same content in them. Right. Well, and you're running like a Git, uh, website, like you're, you're, you're hosting Git for other people as your job. Right. So you're probably going to write some rule that says, look, if this person makes, you know, the same commit all these times, you know, they all have the same content that I'm going to block them or, you know, I'm going to, yeah, block them and then send an email saying, you know, your account's been compromised or what have you
这很有道理。是的，我想，是的。所以，所以只是，是的。使用 Git 就是一个很好的例子。比如，假设有人，嗯，你知道，创建了 1000 万个 Git 提交，它们的内容都完全一样。对吧。那么，如果你在运营一个 Git 网站，比如你的工作就是为其他人托管 Git。对吧。那你很可能会写一些规则，比如，看，如果这个人多次进行相同的提交，你知道，它们的内容都一样，那我就要封禁他们，或者，你知道，我会，是的，封禁他们，然后发一封邮件说，你知道，你的账户可能被盗了，或者诸如此类的情况。
or something bad has happened, right? On the flip side, maybe someone is creating a whole bunch of different commits with different content because they are writing some script that's automatically converting all the tabs to spaces and all their files or something. And for whatever reason, it's creating a lot of commits. And so that might be normal, right? And so getting to Patrick's point, someone could actually, if it's not a cryptographically secure hash function, they could actually figure out a way to be making a lot of different changes, but they're all hashing to the same hash and creating all sorts of problems there. And so it'd be very hard to fix that. But there are times, I mean, a good example of a time to use
或者发生了什么坏事，对吧？反过来说，也许有人因为正在编写某种自动将所有文件中的制表符转换为空格的脚本，而创建了一大堆内容不同的提交。不管出于什么原因，它创建了大量的提交。所以这可能是正常的，对吧？回到帕特里克的观点，如果这不是一个加密安全的哈希函数，有人实际上可以找到一种方法来进行大量的不同更改，但它们都哈希到同一个哈希值，从而造成各种各样的问题。所以要修复这个问题会非常困难。但有些时候，我的意思是，使用非加密安全哈希的一个很好的例子是当你进行这些大数据 ETL 处理时。
hash that's not crypto secure is when you're doing these big data ETL things. So when you're doing like a MapReduce or Spark or one of these things, so just to like not sidetrack too much, but, but the way MapReduce works is you have this enormous volume of data somewhere. And let's say you just want to build a histogram of it. So you want to count the number of times you see Patrick, you want to count the number of times you see the word Jason, you want to count the number of times you see the word programming throwdown. So the way MapReduce will do this is, you know, it will have a ton of different machines that are going to just take a small piece of this massive data set and count the Patrick's and
所以当你进行 MapReduce 或 Spark 或类似的操作时，为了不偏离主题太远，MapReduce 的工作方式是你在某处拥有海量的数据。假设你只是想为它建立一个直方图。所以你想统计你看到“帕特里克”的次数，你想统计你看到“杰森”这个词的次数，你想统计你看到“编程抛出”这个词的次数。所以 MapReduce 的做法是，你知道，它会有大量的不同机器，它们只是获取这个海量数据集的一小部分，并统计帕特里克和
the Jason's and the programming throwdowns. And so then it's going to hash all of those names, right? So Patrick is going to hash to some kind of number. Jason's going to hash some kind of number. Programming throwdown is going to hash to a number. And then it's going to, based on that number, send it to what's called a reducer. And so if you have, let's say 10 reducers, you might say, well, all those numbers that end in a zero go to the first reducer. All those numbers that end in a one go to the second reducer. I guess you'd need 11 reducers, but, but anyway, so right. So then you, you use that to the reducer is going to collect all that information. And so a single reducer knows it's going to have all the Jasons
杰森以及编程抛出的次数。然后它会哈希所有这些名字，对吧？所以帕特里克会哈希成某种数字。杰森会哈希成某种数字。编程抛出会哈希成一个数字。然后，根据那个数字，它会把它发送到所谓的“归约器”（reducer）。所以如果你有，比如说 10 个归约器，你可能会说，所有以 0 结尾的数字都去第一个归约器。所有以 1 结尾的数字都去第二个归约器。我想你需要 11 个归约器，但不管怎样，所以对吧。所以你使用那个归约器来收集所有这些信息。所以单个归约器知道它将拥有所有的杰森，
because JSON is always going to hash to the same thing. And so that's how MapReduce works. And, but for MapReduce, you know, as I said, you're processing these massive data sets and you know, it's not really a cryptography thing. Like there's not really a cryptography thing. Like there's not really any concern about that. And so MapReduce, at least back when I was working on a long time ago, use Murmur. Now it might be using XXHash, which has been proven to be a lot faster. But, you know,
因为杰森总是会哈希成相同的东西。这就是 MapReduce 的工作原理。但是对于 MapReduce，正如我所说，你正在处理这些海量数据集，你知道，这并不是真正的密码学问题。就像没有真正的密码学问题。就像没有真正的担忧。所以 MapReduce，至少在我很久以前工作的时候，使用的是 Murmur。现在它可能正在使用 XXHash，事实证明它快得多。但是，你知道，
that's something where, you know, actually saving that bit of time by using Murmur instead of SHA will actually really matter because the computation there is so intense. And so the hash in HashMaps is needed because ultimately what you're trying to do is take some key. And we should mention, I guess, HashMaps and HashSets are kind of interchangeable. Like it's just kind of the underlying fundamentals are the same as just what data type you use, whether it's just the key only or the key plus some data. And so what you're trying to do with the hash is take arbitrary data, mix it up, combine it, do something in some way to go from an arbitrary,
这确实是那种通过使用 Murmur 而不是 SHA 来节省一点时间确实很重要的地方，因为那里的计算非常密集。所以哈希映射（HashMaps）中需要哈希，因为你最终想要做的是获取某个键。我们应该提到，我想，哈希映射和哈希集合（HashSets）在某种程度上是可以互换的。就像底层的基本原理是一样的，只是你使用的数据类型不同，是只有键还是键加上一些数据。所以你试图用哈希做的是获取任意数据，混合它，组合它，以某种方式从任意的、
any input size of bytes. Imagine a string and you don't know the length of the string right it could be Bob and it could be Sir Ferdinand the Great I don't know like something really big and you want to combine it all down and let's say you want only one byte to represent all of that data how do you mix it up so that your keys are as evenly distributed as possible across your key space. Now the other thing you have is you have the hash function which goes from an arbitrary number of bytes usually like for the ones Jason was mentioning to you
任何输入大小的字节中进行转换。想象一个字符串，你不知道字符串的长度，它可能是“鲍勃”，也可能是“伟大的费迪南德爵士”，我不知道，就像非常大的东西，你想把它全部组合起来，假设你只想用一个字节来表示所有这些数据，你如何混合它，使你的键在你的键空间中尽可能均匀地分布？现在你拥有的另一件事是哈希函数，它从任意数量的字节开始，通常就像杰森提到的那些，到
know 4 bytes or 8 bytes for 64 bits or 256 bytes would be what 16 bytes? No? Yeah that's true. So you end up having, you know, say, let's say four bytes, right? But that's still two to the 32. That's a lot of like keys. And the getting constant time, you have something called a bucket. And a bucket is taking a key and having, you can think of it as an array of a size. So if you is 32 bytes. There we go. Thank you. That makes sense. And so you have these buckets, and the buckets are like slots in your array. So say I have, I want to make my array small to begin with. So I have seven buckets, seven elements in my array. And I have a four byte hash result, right right so i need to get from four bytes down to
4 字节或 8 字节（对于 64 位）或 256 字节（那会是 16 字节吗？不？是的，那是真的）。所以你最终会得到，你知道，比如说，四个字节，对吧？但这仍然是 2 的 32 次方。那有很多键。为了获得恒定时间，你有一种叫做“桶”（bucket）的东西。桶就是获取一个键并拥有，你可以把它想象成一个特定大小的数组。所以如果你是 32 字节。好了。谢谢。这很有道理。所以你有这些桶，桶就像你数组中的槽位。所以假设我有，我想先把我的数组做得很小。所以我有七个桶，数组中有七个元素。我有一个四字节的哈希结果，对吧，所以我需要从四个字节降到
seven um and the way you do that typically i mean there's other variation is is a modulus and if you do the modulus of you know two to the 32 whatever the value is modulus seven then it'll just keep wrapping around and you'll find which slot to uh put your in. Now there is interplay as well that we won't get into about how to choose that when you want more slots than seven, like what do you choose as your next? Do you choose eight? Do you choose another prime number? Seven's prime. And there's some trade-offs there. But ultimately you're taking this hash function and fitting it into your buckets of some size. Now, the size is determined in part by one of the design factors that can end up sort of breaking the constant time assumption by something called the load factor. So the load factor is how many items you have stored in your hash map divided by your current number of buckets. So if you have buckets that are size seven, and you have 14 items you tried to store in seven buckets, then clearly you're going to have at
七，嗯，你通常那样做的方法，我的意思是还有其他变体，是取模。如果你取模，你知道 2 的 32 次方，无论那个值是多少，模 7，那么它就会一直循环，你会找到把你的东西放进哪个槽位。现在还有一种相互作用，我们不会深入讨论，关于当你想要超过七个槽位时如何选择，你选择什么作为你的下一个？你选择八吗？你选择另一个质数吗？七是质数。这里面有一些权衡。但最终你是采用这个哈希函数并将其放入某种大小的桶中。现在，大小在一定程度上是由设计因素决定的，这些因素最终可能会通过所谓的“负载因子”打破恒定时间假设。所以负载因子就是你存储在哈希映射中的项目数量除以你当前的桶数量。所以如果你有大小为 7 的桶，而你试图在 7 个桶中存储 14 个项目，那么显然你会有
least some collisions, and your load factor would be two. Now, when you have collisions, two things mapping to the same slot, there's a variety of ways of handling it um the we'll talk about that in in sort of a minute but in all of the cases the bigger your load factor gets in some hash maps they try to keep or must keep the load factor under one um in other cases you could allow it to grow above one but in both times once the load factor gets too high, you start breaking your constant time assumption. You end up going to linear time, which is worse than logarithmic time. And so you have to be really careful to play this load factor. Now, where the load factor game comes into play is that you end up using more memory
至少一些冲突，你的负载因子将是 2。现在，当你发生冲突时，即两个东西映射到同一个槽位，有多种处理方法，嗯，我们稍后会讨论，但在所有情况下，你的负载因子越大，在某些哈希映射中，它们试图保持或必须保持负载因子低于 1，在其他情况下，你可以允许它增长到 1 以上，但在两种情况下，一旦负载因子变得太高，你就会开始打破你的恒定时间假设。你最终会进入线性时间，这比对数时间更糟糕。所以你必须非常小心地处理这个负载因子。现在，负载因子游戏发挥作用的地方在于你最终会使用更多的内存，
because the smaller your load factor is, you're effectively wasting memory. So if I say, oh, I'm just going to create a, you know, billion entry array, and I'm just going to hash everything to it. And I'm not going to worry about hash collisions. Okay, cool. Except that billion element array is really big in memory, and it's mostly sitting empty. So there's a trade off between memory usage and speed. Yeah. So, I mean, you know, what makes the hash table or hash map or hash set, what makes these things so fast is that hashing is turning some content into a number and that number is then used as an index. And so if you have an array, you know, getting an item from that array from its index is super fast. And so you're kind of turning like you're doing sort of an association, right? That's turning, you know, strings or whatever you want into indices and then just putting it into that spot. But yeah, as Patrick said, the problem is that only makes sense if the array has already been totally allocated in memory and you can go to spot five by doing some arithmetic.
因为你的负载因子越小，你实际上是在浪费内存。所以如果我说，哦，我只是要创建一个，你知道，十亿个条目的数组，我只是要把所有东西都哈希到它里面。我不会担心哈希冲突。好的，酷。除了那个十亿元素的数组在内存中非常大，而且大部分时间是空的。所以内存使用和速度之间存在权衡。是的。所以，我的意思是，你知道，是什么让哈希表或哈希映射或哈希集合，是什么让这些东西如此之快，是因为哈希是将某些内容变成一个数字，然后该数字被用作索引。所以如果你有一个数组，你知道，从那个数组中通过索引获取一个项目是非常快的。所以你有点像在做一种关联，对吧？就是把字符串或任何你想要的东西变成索引，然后直接把它放进那个位置。但是是的，正如帕特里克所说，问题在于只有当数组已经在内存中完全分配，并且你可以通过进行一些算术运算到达位置 5 时，这才有意义。
And so for that whole thing to work, there has to be something, even if it's just empty in spot four and spot three and spot two and spot one, like that space has to be occupied. So we were kind of getting at this load factor hashing about changing your data into a sort of number, modulizing that number by the number of buckets you have, and then looking in that slot. Now, what happens if two things map to the same slot? So it turns out there's roughly two strategies for dealing with it. The first one is called closed addressing. So an example of this is the C++ STL library for their unordered map and unordered set use closed addressing. And there's some variation and complexity about what they do,
所以为了让整个事情工作，必须有东西，即使它只是位置 4、位置 3、位置 2 和位置 1 是空的，那个空间也必须被占用。所以我们刚才谈到了这个负载因子哈希，关于把你的数据变成一种数字，用你拥有的桶的数量对那个数字取模，然后查看那个槽位。现在，如果两个东西映射到同一个槽位会发生什么？事实证明，处理它大约有两种策略。第一种叫做“封闭寻址”（closed addressing）。所以这方面的一个例子是 C++ STL 库，它们的无序映射（unordered map）和无序集合（unordered set）使用封闭寻址。关于它们所做的事情有一些变化和复杂性，
but roughly what ends up happening is if you have a collision, because you could have seven buckets and you insert your first item in index one and then your second thing hashes and you also insert it in text one so you have only two things but they collided and what would happen in the stl library and these closed addressing is you would just make a linked list so you would take put them in the same bucket but but there would be a list. And so when you go to do a lookup, you get the bucket and you say,
但大致发生的情况是，如果你有冲突，因为你可能有七个桶，你在索引 1 处插入了你的第一个项目，然后你的第二个东西哈希了，你也把它插入到了索引 1，所以你只有两个东西，但它们冲突了，在 STL 库和这些封闭寻址中会发生的是，你只会制作一个链表，所以你会把它们放在同一个桶里，但会有一个列表。所以当你去进行查找时，你得到那个桶，然后你说，
does my key match the key at the head of the linked list? If not, go traverse the linked list until you either find the match or you find out that it's not in your set. So that's closed addressing. Yeah, actually, one thing that I wanted to just mention there is, yeah, you have to keep the original key because when you hash something, you've kind of destroyed the original value. Like if I, yeah, if I hash Jason, it's going to give me, you know, 13 or something like
我的键是否与链表头部的键匹配？如果没有，就遍历链表，直到你找到匹配项或者发现它不在你的集合中。这就是封闭寻址。是的，实际上，我想要提到的关于那一点的是，是的，你必须保留原始键，因为当你哈希某物时，你已经破坏了原始值。就像如果我，是的，如果我哈希“杰森”，它会给我，你知道，13 或者类似的东西，
that. And so now Jason is gone. Right. And so, and so in the hash table, when you go to spot 13, you actually still need to store the key again. And that's one thing that kind of confuses a lot of new people when they see hash tables. And so, yeah, so that's to Patrick's point. Like if you're looking for JSON, just because you got to 13, it doesn't mean that you found JSON because it could have been something else hashed to 13.
所以现在“杰森”不见了。对吧。所以，在哈希表中，当你去位置 13 时，你实际上仍然需要再次存储该键。这是很多新手看到哈希表时感到困惑的一件事。所以，是的，这就是帕特里克的观点。就像如果你在寻找“杰森”，仅仅因为你到了 13，并不意味着你找到了“杰森”，因为它可能是其他哈希到 13 的东西。
So that's where you would actually look through that list and say, OK, is there an actual JSON here? And if that list gets really long, that's going to take a long time. Hot tip here too, is I think every one of these things we're calling out, I've heard personally in an interview I've been in, done or listened to. So if you're going to do an interview for a job in Silicon Valley, like every one of these caveats I think we've mentioned so far has come up, at least in my experience. So the nuances here, if for no other reason than interviewing ability are important, but they do actually impact when you get into the subtleties of how your HashMap is performing. Because I do know a lot of people who just slap in a HashMap and assume it works and then move on. And they don't actually measure to see if it's an improvement or if they should tune it. Yeah. One of the things that I was really
所以这就是你会遍历那个列表并说，好的，这里真的有“杰森”吗？如果那个列表变得非常长，那将需要很长时间。这里的一个热门提示是，我想我们提到的每一件事，我都曾在面试中亲自听到过、做过或听过。所以如果你要参加硅谷的工作面试，我想我们目前提到的每一个注意事项都出现过，至少在我的经验中是这样。所以这里的细微差别，即使仅仅是为了面试能力，也是很重要的，但当你深入了解哈希映射性能的微妙之处时，它们确实会产生影响。因为我确实认识很多人，他们只是随便用一个哈希映射，假设它能工作，然后就继续。他们并没有真正测量它是否是一种改进，或者他们是否应该调整它。是的。我真正着迷的一件事，
fascinated by, again, working, so, you know, MapReduce, like working on MapReduce was definitely the time where I was really exposed to a lot of these things because that scale is when you'll really start to see all of the challenges get exposed. And MapReduce switched from using QuickSort to MergeSort. And the reason is because, you know, in QuickSort and MergeSort have the same runtime on average. But if you pick bad pivots which could happen because the data is just structured a certain way and and you're expecting totally
再次，工作，所以，你知道，MapReduce，就像在 MapReduce 上工作绝对是我真正接触到很多这些东西的时候，因为那种规模是你真正开始看到所有挑战暴露出来的时候。MapReduce 从使用快速排序（QuickSort）切换到了归并排序（MergeSort）。原因是因为，你知道，快速排序和归并排序在平均情况下具有相同的运行时间。但是如果你选择了糟糕的枢轴（pivot），这可能会发生，因为数据只是以某种方式结构化，而你期望的是完全
random or arbitrarily distributed data there's actually times where quick sort would you know consistently for this one map reduce quick sort would take almost linear time and and you know this is over you know like billions and billions of items so it just it would basically never finish and so um and so and so we end up switching everything to merge sort and so i think um and so that's that's that's one of these challenges with hash tables too is is um you know especially if you're doing something at scale, is you want to monitor the number of collisions and also something called the smearing, which is just another word for the entropy, really.
随机或任意分布的数据，实际上有几次快速排序会，你知道，对于这个特定的 MapReduce，快速排序几乎需要线性时间，而且，你知道，这是在，你知道，像数十亿数十亿的项目上，所以它基本上永远不会完成，所以，嗯，所以我们最终把所有东西都切换到了归并排序，所以我认为，嗯，所以这就是哈希表的挑战之一，就是，你知道，特别是如果你在规模上做某事，你想监控冲突的数量，还有所谓的“涂抹”（smearing），这只是熵的另一个词，真的。
But you want to measure the entropy of your hash table. So in other words, you want to see that a lot of the items in the hash table, all the cells in the hash table are either empty or filled with one or two or three things. And yeah, just keep a constant eye on it. And you're right, it does come up a lot in interviews, trying to understand that whole,
但你想测量你的哈希表的熵。换句话说，你想看到哈希表中的很多项目，哈希表中的所有单元格要么是空的，要么填充了一两个或三个东西。是的，只要一直关注它。你是对的，它在面试中确实经常出现，试图理解整个，
like understand all of those dynamics. So if we gave the name closed addressing, it doesn't take much, I guess, to figure out the alternative is open addressing. So if you end up with a collision and you're using an open addressing hash map then you use some mechanism for finding another bucket, another slot in your array to go look at to see if your key is there. So the easiest one to kind of think about is when inserting, if I insert and there's already something there, then I just do my bucket plus one. And then I look,
就像理解所有这些动态。所以如果我们给出了“封闭寻址”这个名字，我想弄清楚替代方案是“开放寻址”（open addressing）并不需要太多。所以如果你最终遇到了冲突，并且你正在使用开放寻址哈希映射，那么你使用某种机制来寻找另一个桶，即数组中的另一个槽位，去看看你的键是否在那里。所以最容易想到的一个是插入时，如果我插入并且那里已经有东西了，那么我就做我的桶加 1。然后我查看，
is there something there? And if so, go bucket plus two, right? And I just keep walking down. And you could do linear probe, quadratic probe, right? You're just basically looking and kind of iterating through all of the buckets, looking for one that's open. And then at accessing, you just do kind of like the opposite, you would go to your array, if that item, if the bucket is empty, you're done. But if the bucket has an item, and it doesn't match your key, then you have to follow sort of the same probing as the insertion algorithm use. And there's a variety of these. And these actually, and I'll talk about why in a second, but there's there's cuckoo hashing, Robin Hood hashing. So like in Robin Hood hashing, you measure how far away from your original slot
那里有东西吗？如果有，就去桶加 2，对吧？我就一直往下走。你可以做线性探测、二次探测，对吧？你基本上只是在查看并遍历所有的桶，寻找一个开放的。然后在访问时，你只是做类似相反的操作，你会去你的数组，如果那个项目，如果桶是空的，你就完成了。但如果桶里有一个项目，并且它与你的键不匹配，那么你必须遵循与插入算法使用的相同的探测方式。这里有各种各样的。这些实际上，我稍后会谈到原因，但有布谷鸟哈希（cuckoo hashing）、罗宾汉哈希（Robin Hood hashing）。所以就像在罗宾汉哈希中，你测量每个元素距离它原始槽位有多远，
each element is. And you use that to decide whether to keep looking or to displace the elements that they are put yours in and then move that one further down so that you're trying to get your keys as close to their original bucket as possible. And the reason why these end up mattering and why this versus like the linked list approach from closed addressing matters is because again, algorithmically,
并用它来决定是继续寻找还是置换那些已经放入你的东西的元素，然后把那个移得更远，这样你就可以尝试让你的键尽可能靠近它们原始的桶。这些最终之所以重要，以及为什么这与封闭寻址的链表方法不同之所以重要，是因为再次，从算法上讲，
these are constant time insertion and lookup on average but in practice you have problems with cache efficiency in a linked list if i don't pay attention i go look up one key and then it's not correct and so i have to traverse the linked list but that item in memory could be at an entirely different place in ram just based on wherever i got it from my allocator off the heap and I have to wait for the processor to go through all of its caches out to RAM, pull in that value, and access it, right? So the cache efficiency there is very different than if I have two slots in an array, which will be consecutive in memory, and I just need to look at the first one and then the second one,
这些在平均情况下是恒定时间的插入和查找，但在实践中，如果你不注意，在链表中会有缓存效率的问题，我去查找一个键，然后它不正确，所以我必须遍历链表，但内存中的那个项目可能完全在 RAM 的不同地方，这仅仅取决于我从堆分配器中获取它的位置，我必须等待处理器通过它所有的缓存到达 RAM，拉入那个值，并访问它，对吧？所以那里的缓存效率与我如果数组中有两个槽位（它们在内存中是连续的）的情况非常不同，我只需要查看第一个，然后是第二个，
because the way the processor works is it doesn't just fetch your value from RAM and into cache. It fetches, it's called sort of a cache line. It fetches a bunch of memory all at once into the cache. And then so it expects that your next lookup is close to your first lookup when you're accessing memory. And so these open addressing ones try to leverage that realization to make much more cache efficient ways of accessing the hash buckets. So yeah, one question, when you're doing the open addressing, how do you know when to stop?
因为处理器的工作方式是，它不仅仅是从 RAM 获取你的值到缓存中。它获取，这被称为一种缓存行（cache line）。它一次性将一大块内存获取到缓存中。所以它期望当你访问内存时，你的下一次查找接近你的第一次查找。所以这些开放寻址方法试图利用这种认识，使访问哈希桶的方式更具缓存效率。所以是的，一个问题，当你进行开放寻址时，你怎么知道什么时候停止？
Like, let's say the hash table is full, right? Yep. So you stop when either you get to an empty bucket or when you have if it's completely full and you've gone all the way around but these are much more sensitive so closed addressing and i i might someone will tell me i'm wrong that's fine closed addressing you can have a load factor over one open addressing you could never have a load factor over one right it'll crash or something right because it just won't be able to insert like yeah you have no you can't insert the last thing as soon as you go over one and if you have one then you're right any checking for any value not in the set will require you to iterate all buckets. Yeah, the only alternative
比如，假设哈希表满了，对吧？是的。所以你要么在到达一个空桶时停止，要么如果你已经完全满了，并且你已经绕了一圈，但这些更敏感，所以封闭寻址，我，可能会有人告诉我我错了，没关系，封闭寻址你可以有超过 1 的负载因子，开放寻址你永远不能有超过 1 的负载因子，对吧？它会崩溃或类似的情况，对吧？因为它只是无法插入，就像是的，你没有，你不能插入最后一个东西，一旦你超过 1，如果你有 1，那么你是对的，检查任何不在集合中的值都需要你遍历所有桶。是的，唯一的替代方案
would be you'd have to also store the hash. So like in every bucket, you'd have to store what the hash would have been if there were no collisions. Yes, there are. So there are also hybrid hash maps, I think that kind of start to use rehashing methods. So rather than using a single hash, you use a different seed and you hash again, or multiple bucket lists. But yeah, so Oh, no, I was saying something a little different. I was saying like, so let's say you're doing linear probing, right? And so but but let's say in the hash table, along with the key, you're also storing the hash of the key. Or I guess you could just do it on the fly. So like if you're doing the linear probing and you're looking for Apple and Apple hashes to two, and then you go to the next one and that item, whatever that is, if it doesn't hash to two, then you know to stop, even if the hash table is full.
是你也必须存储哈希值。所以就像在每个桶里，你必须存储如果没有冲突的话哈希值会是什么。是的，有。所以也有混合哈希映射，我想它们开始使用再哈希方法。所以与其使用单个哈希，你使用不同的种子并再次哈希，或者多个桶列表。但是是的，所以，哦，不，我刚才说的是有点不同。我说的是，所以，假设你正在进行线性探测，对吧？所以，但是，假设在哈希表中，除了键之外，你还存储了键的哈希值。或者我想你可以直接在运行中做。所以就像如果你正在进行线性探测，并且你在寻找“苹果”，而“苹果”哈希到 2，然后你转到下一个，那个项目，无论那是什么，如果它没有哈希到 2，那么你就知道停止了，即使哈希表是满的。
But then like, you're either like doing a lot of hashes or you'd have to somehow like store the hash or something. Yeah. Does that make sense? Maybe. I don't want to get into a design review of your algorithm. I feel something else could be hashed to three. So you could have some dog was hashed at three.
但是然后，就像，你要么是做了很多哈希，要么你必须以某种方式存储哈希值或类似的东西。是的。这有意义吗？也许。我不想对你的算法进行设计审查。我觉得其他东西可能被哈希到 3。所以你可能有一些“狗”被哈希到 3。
Yeah, but I'm saying like, okay, so let's say the thing you're searching for, your query hashes to two, right? And you go to that spot and there's something that hashes to two, but it's not your item, right? So then you go to the next spot and if that thing in that next spot doesn't hash to two then you're done right but i'm saying something else could have already been there yeah oh and then you have to jump over it yes oh and actually actually now i think about it so this is this is uh yeah this is bringing back a lot of memories so actually when you when you when you um if something if there's something that doesn't hash to two in that spot that you're in right now it
是的，但我说的是，好的，所以，假设你正在搜索的东西，你的查询哈希到 2，对吧？你去了那个位置，那里有东西哈希到 2，但它不是你的项目，对吧？所以你转到下一个位置，如果那个下一个位置的东西没有哈希到 2，那么你就完成了，对吧？但我说的是其他东西可能已经在那儿了。是的，哦，然后你必须跳过它。是的，哦，实际上，现在我想起来了，所以这是，是的，这带回了很多记忆，所以实际上当你，当你，当你，如果有什么东西，如果那个你现在所在的位置没有哈希到 2，它
could be that apple is still there it just yes got there too late yes and like someone else oh yeah okay so yeah you're right you have to go through the entire hash table worst case yeah see i would totally fail actually just just to circle back something you said earlier, I've actually never had a hash table kind of question, but you could tell I would totally fail that. But I think it is super important. I think, you know, don't panic if like your background is in something else. I don't know if you'll get maybe these kinds of questions,
可能是“苹果”仍然在那里，它只是，是的，到得太晚了，是的，就像其他人，哦，是的，好的，所以，是的，你是对的，你必须遍历整个哈希表，最坏的情况。是的，看，我实际上会完全失败，只是为了回到你刚才说的一些事情，我实际上从来没有遇到过哈希表之类的问题，但你可以看出我会完全失败。但我认为这超级重要。我认为，你知道，如果你的背景是其他东西，不要惊慌。我不知道你是否会得到这些类型的问题，
but it's still really good to know. Okay, I've seen good interviews and bad interviews. I won't speak to bad interviews, but in good interviews, I think they're actually hoping you don't know the answer because they don't care. They want you to be able like Jason just did, like, Oh, have this idea. Oh, wait, this idea doesn't work. And then, you know, be able to make the progression to refining your idea or discovering something that's already in literature that maybe your interview already knows about. But they're letting you sort of do it from first principles and seeing how your brain unpacks the problems. Yeah, it's a good call. So if you really, really want the cheat code, then there's something called the minimal perfect hash. So the idea here is if you know up front
但知道这些仍然非常好。好的，我见过好的面试和坏的面试。我不会谈论坏的面试，但在好的面试中，我认为他们实际上希望你不知道答案，因为他们不在乎。他们希望你能够像杰森刚才那样，哦，有这个想法。哦，等等，这个想法行不通。然后，你知道，能够进行改进你的想法或发现文献中已经存在的东西的进展，也许你的面试官已经知道了。但他们让你从第一性原理出发，看看你的大脑是如何解构问题的。是的，说得好。所以如果你真的，真的想要作弊码，那么有一种东西叫做“最小完美哈希”（minimal perfect hash）。所以这里的想法是，如果你预先知道
all the items you're going to hash, say 397 of them, then you make exactly 397 buckets and you find the hash function which one-to-one maps all of your input keys to your bucket list with zero collisions. These are pretty cool because you have a perfectly space efficient answer. And the only problem is, how do you search the space of hash functions to find such a perfect hash? And there's a class of ones that you can narrow in on and how to structure this problem. It's a very interesting, sort of research topic. I've never seen it used in practice, but it is a really cool idea that you could have the best of all worlds, a constant time lookup, no wasted space, a load factor of one
所有你要哈希的项目，比如说 397 个，那么你制作 397 个桶，并找到那个将你所有的输入键一对一映射到你的桶列表且零冲突的哈希函数。这些非常酷，因为你有一个空间效率完美的答案。唯一的问题是，你如何搜索哈希函数空间来找到这样一个完美的哈希？有一类你可以缩小范围的哈希函数，以及如何构建这个问题。这是一个非常有趣的，某种研究课题。我从来没在实践中见过它被使用，但它是一个非常酷的想法，你可以拥有两全其美的结果，恒定时间查找，没有浪费的空间，负载因子为 1，
and guarantee that you would instantly know if a key is in your set or not. It's just really awesome. The problem is it becomes very, very expensive to find this perfect hash. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, the only way I could think to do it as a person who has no experience would be to just try adding salt and just keep doing that until, but that's going to take forever. I mean, the odds that... You've just discovered Bitcoin mining. Yeah, I guess so.
并保证你会立即知道一个键是否在你的集合中。这真的很棒。问题是找到这个完美哈希变得非常、非常昂贵。是的，这有意义。是的，我的意思是，作为一个没有经验的人，我能想到的唯一方法就是尝试添加盐（salt），然后一直这样做直到，但这需要永远。我的意思是，几率……你刚刚发现了比特币挖矿。是的，我想是这样。
Yeah, I think, I mean, the odds that you eventually hit that right hash are just Oh, for people who don't know, a salt is, a salt is very simple. It's something that you add to all of your keys that just make the hashing work differently. Oh, yeah, yeah. Okay. And the reason why, correct me if I'm wrong on this, or feel free to fill in the holes here, but I think the reason why they use salt is not to try and find better hash functions, but the idea is the salt is something that you as the programmer know, but someone on the outside doesn't know. And so if someone, let's say, gets a hold of your database, but they don't know your salt because they don't have the source code, then there are certain tricks
是的，我想，我的意思是，你最终命中那个正确哈希的几率只是，哦，对于不知道的人，盐，盐非常简单。它是你添加到所有键中的东西，只是让哈希工作得不同。哦，是的，是的。好的。而原因，如果我在这方面错了请纠正我，或者随意填补这里的漏洞，但我认为他们使用盐的原因不是为了尝试找到更好的哈希函数，而是想法是盐是你作为程序员知道，但外面的人不知道的东西。所以如果有人，假设，拿到了你的数据库，但他们不知道你的盐，因为他们没有源代码，那么有一些技巧
that they can't use. Like for example, let's say someone has a database full of hashed passwords. Well, they know that a lot of people out there make their password the word password. So they'll just run like the hash function. They'll like look at all the popular hash functions and run them all on the word password and see the numbers that come out of that or the hash function, they'll like look at all the popular hash functions and run them all on the word password and see the numbers that come out of that or the hash, let's say that comes out of that. And, um, and just see like, okay, which of these hashes is in your database a lot. Okay. It's this one. Therefore you're using this type of hash function. And then knowing that allows them to do a bunch of other things. But if you've put a salt in, now you don't have a whole bunch of hashed words of password.
他们不能使用。比如，假设有人有一个装满哈希密码的数据库。好吧，他们知道外面很多人把他们的密码设为“密码”这个词。所以他们只会运行像哈希函数。他们会，就像查看所有流行的哈希函数，并把它们全部运行在“密码”这个词上，看看出来的数字，或者哈希函数，他们会，就像查看所有流行的哈希函数，并把它们全部运行在“密码”这个词上，看看出来的数字，或者哈希，假设出来的是那个。而且，嗯，只是看看，好的，这些哈希中哪一个在你的数据库中很多。好的。是这个。因此你正在使用这种类型的哈希函数。然后知道这一点允许他们做很多其他事情。但如果你加了盐，现在你没有一大堆“密码”的哈希词。
Now you have a bunch of hashes of, you know, my cool salt password and my cool salt Abba and my cool salt Patrick and whatever. And just like, you know, even though you added the same thing to every key, it's going to cause the hashes to be totally different. Yep. That's right. And so, yeah, I think, uh, so getting back to Patrick saying like, you could just try like adding, trying different salts until you get one that hashes these 300 things in a 300 unique like integers after you've modded them. Uh, but that will take forever. Not forever. Just a long time. Not literally forever.
现在你有一堆，你知道，“我的酷盐密码”和“我的酷盐阿巴”和“我的酷盐帕特里克”等等的哈希。而且就像，你知道，即使你给每个键添加了相同的东西，它也会导致哈希完全不同。是的。那是对的。所以，是的，我想，嗯，所以回到帕特里克说的，就像，你可以尝试，就像添加，尝试不同的盐，直到你得到一个，在你对它们取模后，将这 300 个东西哈希成 300 个唯一整数的盐。嗯，但这需要永远。不是永远。只是很长时间。不是字面上的永远。
But yeah, really, really, really long time. Yeah, I mean, definitely. I mean, intractably long time. Like not long as in come back in a week. Long as in like your whole lifetime. Like more than that. Another thing that I've used hashing a lot for which is like very different
但是是的，真的，真的，真的很长时间。是的，我的意思是，绝对。我的意思是，难以置信的长。不像“回来一周”那么长。长到像你的一生。甚至比那还长。我使用哈希的另一件事，这与
from the traditional hashing, but still really useful, is locality-sensitive hashing. And this is kind of the opposite of everything we just talked about for goals for hashing. In locality-sensitive hashing, you actually want things that are similar to hash to the same number, right? So imagine a map, right? Like a map of United States, right? And you have a bunch of points on the map. And so maybe all the points represent different businesses or something, right? And so in this case, you want to hash the points that are close together to the same number because that number is going to represent, let's say, a file on disk that has all the names of the businesses.
传统的哈希非常不同，但仍然非常有用，是“局部敏感哈希”（locality-sensitive hashing）。这与我们刚才谈到的哈希目标正好相反。在局部敏感哈希中，你实际上希望相似的东西哈希成相同的数字，对吧？所以想象一张地图，对吧？就像一张美国地图，对吧？你在地图上有一堆点。所以也许所有的点代表不同的企业或类似的东西，对吧？所以在这个例子中，你希望将靠得很近的点哈希成相同的数字，因为那个数字将代表，比如说，磁盘上的一个文件，它拥有所有企业的名称。
And so when you're looking on Google Maps, you're probably looking at a whole area. And so you're probably looking at a bunch of businesses, but they're all close together spatially. You want to hash all of those to the same number so that all the names of the businesses come from the same file on disk, right? And so that's locality sensitive hashing. And so in that case, you're not worried about collisions. It's kind of a different use case, but you still get a lot of benefit. You get a lot of the order one type benefits. So imagine if you now have a bunch of these points from your map,
所以当你查看谷歌地图时，你可能正在查看整个区域。所以你可能正在查看一堆企业，但它们在空间上都靠得很近。你希望将所有这些哈希成相同的数字，以便所有企业的名称都来自磁盘上的同一个文件，对吧？这就是局部敏感哈希。所以在那情况下，你不担心冲突。这是一种不同的用例，但你仍然获得了很多好处。你获得了很多 O(1) 类型的好处。所以想象一下，如果你现在有来自地图的一堆这些点，
or maybe even you have a region of points, right? And you can feed this through this locality sensitive hash, maybe feed the boundaries or Monte Carlo it or what have you. And it'll say, okay, the hashes are three, four, and five. And then you can load those files, which might have businesses that are outside of the range, but they're all going to be kind of in that area because of the way you've done the hashing. And that's how a lot of these kind of spatial databases work. Awesome. Yeah, this is a really good episode.
或者也许你有一个点的区域，对吧？你可以通过这个局部敏感哈希输入它，也许输入边界或蒙特卡洛模拟它或什么的。它会说，好的，哈希值是 3、4 和 5。然后你可以加载那些文件，它们可能包含范围之外的企业，但因为你进行哈希的方式，它们都会在那个区域内。这就是很多这种空间数据库的工作方式。太棒了。是的，这是一个非常好的剧集。
This is very fun. Yeah. I mean, hash tables and trees, you know, it's sort of like, uh, there's that saying that, uh, you know, with a, uh, uh, with a linear saw and a hammer, like you could do just about anything. Like you build a whole house just with a linear saw and a hammer. I feel like trees and hash tables are kind of like that for us. Like trees and hash tables, you can build just about... Things like arrays and algebra, that's all primitives, right? But with those two data structures, you could build just about everything. And a 55-gallon drum of water.
这非常有趣。是的。我的意思是，哈希表和树，你知道，这有点像，嗯，有句谚语说，嗯，你知道，用一把线性锯和一把锤子，就像你可以做几乎任何事情。就像你只用一把线性锯和一把锤子就能盖一整栋房子。我觉得树和哈希表对我们来说就是那样。就像树和哈希表，你可以构建几乎……像数组和代数这样的东西，那都是原语，对吧？但有了这两个数据结构，你可以构建几乎所有东西。还有一个 55 加仑的水桶。
Yeah, that's right. You could pass the computer science GRE with a 55-gallon drum of water, a water computer, and trees and hashtags. Music by Eric Feindler. music by eric barnmeller programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，那是对的。你可以用一个 55 加仑的水桶、一台水计算机以及树和哈希表通过计算机科学 GRE。音乐由 Eric Feindler 提供。音乐由 Eric Barnmeller 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供对帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。